GOOD AFTERNOON HOW WE WILL
CONVENE NOW THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY IS THAT MAY
REVISED HEARING ON HIGHER
EDUCATION PROPOSALS FOR THE UC
CSU AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM- FIRST LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. SELECT ACTUAL HAVE FOR
YEARS LET'S LET'S HOLD OFF ON
THAT. THIS OF COURSE IS A
UNIQUE- HEARING PROCESS WITH-
VIRTUAL TESTIMONY AND PUBLIC
COMMENT OVER THE PHONE SO I'M
GOING TO READ OFF SOME OVERALL
INSTRUCTIONS- YOU KNOW THIS IS-
THE DISTANCE- PARTICIPATION
PHYSICAL DISTANCING ANSWER
USING TECHNOLOGY TO INTEGRATE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AND
ENGAGEMENT TODAY WHEN A THANK
ARE SIMPLY TEAM WITH THE
SERGEANTS THE SOME THE RULES
COMMITTEE THE SPEAKERS TEAM THE
LEADS HAVE DATA CENTER FOR
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THIS WORKS
FOR CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OF US.
AND I HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
INSTRUCTIONS ON WHAT TO READ
TODAY WE'RE IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICAL
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HERE AND WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC SO IF YOU DO WANT TO
ATTEND AND PARTICIPATE MAKE
SURE YOU SPREAD OUT AND IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK. UP PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU- LESS NOW WILL POINT
YOU IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WHEN
IT'S TIME- WHEN PUBLIC POT
COMMENT BEGINS WE ASK YOU TO
COME UP AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- BUT COME UP TO THE
LINE UP THERE. AND SPEAK FOR
ONE LAST AND THEN A TWO YEAR
AND- PLEASE LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS MOTHERS CAN CAN%
PARTICIPATE FOR A LIST
PARTICIPATING REMOTE WE WILL.
KEEP YOU WHEN IT'S A AND YOUR
YOUR OF COURSE. IN A ROOM ARE
SITE REMOTE. DISSIPATE WE ARE
USING MODERATE TELEPHONE%
SERVICE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION. STAFF ALREADY TO.
INDIVIDUALS HOW TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS ON OUR WEBSITE IN THE
AGENDA THERE IS THERE IT IN
ADDITION. THERE IS A CALL THE
NUMBER. IT'S ON THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT'S ON THE AGENDA IT'S
ON THE TV SCREEN BUT ONE MORE
TIME AS WELL IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE NUMBER IT'S ONE. IN SEVEN.
1-095-718-7769 TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN.
EACH INDIVIDUAL WILL BE GIVEN
INSTRUCTIONS ON WHEN TO SPEAK
AND AGAIN WE WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE PUBLIC COMMENT PER
PERSON. IF YOU HAVING
DIFFICULTY- FIGURE IT OUT YOU
CAN ALSO CALL OUR- OFFICE LOOK-
AND YOU CAN GET INFORMATION HOW
TO CONNECT TO THE SYSTEM THAT
NUMBER FOR THE COULD BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
IN. ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE AS WELL YOU CAN
EMAIL YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. AND THAT
EMAIL ADDRESSES ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. SO THAT WE
ARE GOING TO- START OUR HEARING
TODAY. ON HIGHER EDUCATION IN
THE MAY REVISE WE DID NOT HAVE
A HEARING- AFTER WITH THE
PANDEMIC- SHUT US DOWN
ESSENTIALLY MARCH IS OUR FIRST
TIME TO TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT.
OF THESE CLOSURES ON OUR
STUDENTS AND CAMPUSES WE KNOW
IT'S BEEN A HUGE CHALLENGE FOR
OUR- LAST THREE MONTHS FOR. OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND CAMPUS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AT THE
TRANSITION TO ONLINE HAS BEEN-
EASIER FOR SOME THAN OTHERS WE
KNOW THERE ARE RISING COSTS
WITH OUR CAMPUSES ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL. WELL ESPECIALLY
NO SPECIAL FUNDS A LOST REVENUE
FROM HOUSING AND PARKING TO
ATHLETICS. AND ALL OF OUR
SEGMENTS ARE HEMORRHAGING AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WINNER WE
WENT UNDERSTAND THE MAGNITUDE
OF THAT TODAY AS WELL AS TALK
ABOUT. WHAT WE CAN DO TO KEEP
OUR STUDENTS ALL. CAMPUS ANSWER
SEOUL A SPEAKING ABOUT STUDENTS
THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE'RE
PARTICULAR WORRIED ABOUT. WE
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE EQUITY
GAPS HAVE WHY IN- WHEN THE
STUDENTS WERE BARELY HANGING IN
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE THIS.
COVERT NINETEEN HAS REALLY BEEN
A DISASTER FOR THEM. AND THEIR
FINANCIAL WHERE WITH ALL TO BE
TO BE A COLLEGE STUDENT AND
SURVIVE SIXTY EIGHT. AND MANY
STUDENTS ARE JUGGLING CARING
FOR FAMILIES AND RELATIVES
WATER TRYING TO PASS IS
STUDYING. HOW THERE. ARE L. WE
WITH DAN THE. THIS IS A
DIFFICULT AND AS A IS THE- AT
THE CASE. ABOUT THAT TO. I ON
TOP OF THAT NOW WE FACE MAY BY
GAP FREE TO THE SEGMENTS REALLY
TO THINGS ONE THE INCREASES
FROM THE JAN BY WHAT ARE ALL
THE TABLE AND AS WE KNOW ALL
THE SEGMENT HAD ARTICULATED
THOSE WERE BARELY ENOUGH TO
HANG ON THE FIRST PLACE SO
THAT'S A DOUBLE DOUBLE HIT
THOSE ARE GONE AND THE SECOND
HERE IT IS. IS THE FACT THAT.
THERE MAY BE A ADDITIONAL CUTS
IF WE DON'T GET OUR FEDERAL
STIMULUS MONEY THROUGH THE NEXT
ROUND SO WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THEIR THE
PROPOSED. 10% CUTS ACROSS THE
BOARD- AS FAR AS FINANCIAL AID-
YOU KNOW WE'RE FORTUNATE THAT
THAT MAY REVISED- PROPOSAL-
PRETTY MUCH SPARE IS THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS- PRIDE ON THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CAL GRANT
REFORM EXPANSION THIS YEAR-
MISTER MEDINA WHICH YOU ARE
WORKING ON BUT- AT LEAST WE'RE
NOT GOING TO- WHACKED THESE
PROGRAMS AND FURTHER HIM. SB
BILLET PAY FOR COLLEGE AND AS
WE DO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL CUTS AND AS I SAID
YESTERDAY. WE SHOULD WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS OUR WHAT IS OUR
PLAN BEING PLANCY WE SHOULD
NECESSARILY- A KNOWLEDGE THAT.
IF WE DON'T GET THE FEDERAL
MONIES FOR THE SECOND ROUND OF
THE OF THE STIMULUS THAT. THESE
TRIGGER CUTS WHAT HAPPENED NEED
TO THINK ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT
OTHER OPTIONS WE HAVE WHETHER
TO INCREASE REVENUES GOING TO
THE VOTERS INTERNAL BORROWING I
THINK THEY'RE A LOT OF TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX INTO FOR A FULL THE
VALUE BEFORE WE AKE A LOOK. AT
CUTS BUT IF WE HAVE TO GO DOWN
THAT ROAD. I THINK WE SHOULD
REALLY CONSIDER USING A SCALPEL
AND NOT THE AXE- LAST COUPLE
YEARS WE TALKED ABOUT SOME
AREAS OF UC AND CSU. AND THE
FIVE THEY HAVE IN THE ADMIN
SITE. MAYBE THEY'LL SHOULD TAKE
MORE OF A CUT THANK STUDENT
THEN- FUNDING AT THE CAMPUS
LEVEL WHERE THEY HAVE A MORE
DIRECT IMPACT ON STUDENTS. AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS WE
KNOW WE HAVE LITTLE ACCESS
MONEY AND CAL BRIGHT ONLINE
COLLEGE SYSTEM SO THERE ARE A
FEW. PLACES WE THINK WE SHOULD
TAKE A LOOK BEFORE. A DRASTIC-
GO AFTER OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
CAMPUSES SO. I WILL DO THAT WE
BEGIN. KHN ATION. THAT THE E.
L. L. PERMANENT. AND SEE SEE CA.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND
STUDENT. ARE GONNA HEAR ALL.
I'M SKEWS ME YES ORGAN HERE
ALL. OF THE- OF THE- PANELISTS-
AND THEN WE WILL GET TO-
QUESTIONS ENGAGEMENT FROM THE
MEMBERS- SO WE'RE NOT GONNA
JUST ONE IN A TIME THAT MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO HAVE THEM ALL GO
AND THEN WE WILL. ENGAGE BUT
BEFORE WE START ANY COMMENTS TO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I SEE MISTER MEDINA. MR
MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
CLOUT THE DISCUSS WE'RE HAVING
HERE TODAY IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT I TAKE LIGHTLY. ESPECIALLY
IS THE CHAIR OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. IT IS A STARK
CONTRAST TO THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD ABOUT REFORMING
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM. AS MR
MCCARTY A NOTED EARLIER. TO
INCREASE ACCESS ELIGIBILITY AND
AWARDS TO HELP MORE STUDENTS.
TO FOR THE COST OF COLLEGE. TO
BE SITTING HERE NOW FACING A
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET DEFICIT. IS
DEVASTATING. EVERY CUT TO
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING
REPRESENTS A STIFLED ACADEMIC
ENVIRONMENT. POTENTIAL FACULTY
PARTTIME FACULTY AND STAFF
LAYOFFS. INCREASE BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS PURSUING A COLLEGE
DEGREE. AND GROWING STUDENT
DEBT. THE PANDEMIC IS CREATED A
NEW ECONOMIC REALITY. ONCE THE
ONE THAT WE HAVE TO RECONCILE
AS WE WORK TO DEVELOP A
BALANCED BUDGET. AS THE
GOVERNOR SAID AS PER PRESS
CONFERENCE LAST WEEK. ALL MADE
IT. LIFTING CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
DURING THIS THIS IS STORE BURKE
SURE. THAT WE HAVE. THE TENANTS
OF EQUITY EQUALITY ACCESS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND AT THE
LOWER LEVEL AS WE MAKE TOUGH
DECISIONS. AND PRIOR. TIES ARE
UNDER WRAPS SENATE. AND FIRST
DURATION STUDENTS. THOUGH WE
HAVE TOUGH CONVERSATIONS AHEAD.
I ALSO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR DECISIONS NOT
ARE. OR WHOLE GENERATION OF
STUDENTS. THOSE WHO ARE READY
HIGHER CASE INSTITUTIONS. AND
THOSE RECEIPTS. AND WE IN
LEGISLATURE NEED TO X. DO DEL.
TO REDUCE THE PROGRAM AND
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING OF WITH
THE GRAY NEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YES THANK YOU FOR SENDING
IT UP AS WELL MR MEDINA. WE
KNOW THAT YOU CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
THIS CHAIRING THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACTS OF
THESE BUDGET. DECISIONS ARE
GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT TODAY SO
WITH THAT LET'S HAVE THE LA-
WALK IS THROUGH THE MAY REVISE
HOW IT RELATES TO OUR
CALIFORNIA A YES- WE'RE ALSO
JOINED TODAY BY OUR BUDGET
SHARE A MISTER TING WHO WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. SAY SOMETHING AS
WELL JUST VERY VERY I THINK.
WE'RE PROBABLY RIVERSIDE IS THE
CELL. I WANTED THE ISSUE THE
ISSUE A WHOLE FIFTY TO HAVE
ACCESS. BUT ALSO SURE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN CHRIS EQUITY I THINK
THREE IN DELIBERATIONS OF THE
GET HELP PUBLIC RIVERSIDE VERY
GOOD VERY VERY WELL THAT WE
SHOULD. CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON.
HOW THE- OUR- FIRST REFORM OF
BOTH THEIR ARCS THIS WILL THEIR
EDUCATION SO IF WE HAPPEN TO IT.
I THINK THEY ARE ACROSS THE-
TEMPERATURES BECAUSE SCENES
THAT LIKE A LITTLE COVERS YOU
THE ANSWER I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK A LITTLE BIT DEEPER TO THE
SIDE ARE THERE AREAS WHERE SHE
WHICH SHOULD BE CUT MORE AS
SUCH AS ADMINISTRATION AND
OVERHEAD. IN AREAS THAT SHOULD
BE SPARED SUCH AS STUDENT AID
AND FACULTY SO I THINK WE HAVE
TO MAKE THOSE VERY TOUGH
DECISIONS I KNOW THAT WELL NONE
OF US WERE HERE DURING THE
LAST. BUDGET CRISIS I LOOK
AROUND THE ROOM AND I KNOW MANY
OF US FOR A CITY COUNCILS. AND
COMMUNICATE WITH PORTS ON
SCHOOL BOARDS WERE WE HAD TO
MAKE VERY VERY TOUGH DECISIONS
THEY HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY SO WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S AT STAKE. BUT
AGAIN I FEEL VERY- HONORED TO
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
WITH EVERYBODY AND THE WEALTH
OF EXPERIENCE THAT JUST IN THIS
ROOM BUT ALSO WITHIN OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER I FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD AND I OR TIES.
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS AND EQUITY
HOW WILL MAKE YOU SOME VERY
VERY DIFFICULT DECISION SO
THANK YOU. OKAY WITH THAT LET'S
ASK THE- LA TO BEGIN. JENNIFER
BUT SHALLOW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YOU SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT IN
FRONT OF YOU ENTITLED OVERVIEW
AND ASSESSMENT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. AND THE NEIGHBOR
VISION HAS MANY HIGHER
EDUCATION PROPOSALS THE HAND
THAT IS INTENDED TO SHOW YOU
ALL OF THOSE PROPOSALS APART
FROM A FEW WORKLOAD AND
LANGUAGE ONLY ADJUSTMENTS FOR
THE SAKE OF TIME I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON JUST THE LARGER OF THE
PROPOSAL'S. PAGE ONE OF THE
HANDOUT. SUMMARIZES THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AS YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THE STATE HAS A LARGE
BUDGET PROBLEM. THE GOVERNOR IS
TAKING A MIX OF BUDGET
STRATEGIES TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM WITHIN HIGHER
EDUCATION GOVERNOR USES THE
SAME A STRATEGY OF TAKING A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
BUDGET. SOLUTIONS THE FIRST
THING HE DOES IS WITHDRAW THE
ALMOST ALL OF THE JANUARY
PROPOSALS JANUARY AUGMENTATIONS
SO FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HE WITH PROCESS PROPOSALS TO
GIVE A COLA. HE READ IF DRAWS
HIS HALF A PERCENT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH PROPOSAL. FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S HE WITHDRAWS THE
PROPOSALS TO PROVIDE 5% BASING
CREE SAYS. HE RESENTS ALMOST
ALL OF THE ONE TIME INITIATIVES
THAT HE HAD IN PLACE- HE ALSO
RESIDENTS THINGS LIKE
AUGMENTING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN A FEW CASES HE
DOESN'T REST AND THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL IN ITS ENTIRETY. I'M
IN THE CASE FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
UC RIVERSIDE MED SCHOOL AND THE
UCSF FRESNO BRANCH CAMPUS HE
JUST SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCES THE
SIZE OF THOSE AUGMENTATIONS.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO RESIDENTS
JUST A FEW OF THE NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE TIME INITIATIVES
MOST NOTABLY HERE SINCE THE
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION THAT THE
STATE PROVIDED ONE TIME LAST
YEAR FOR A TEACHER AND SIGNED
OF PROGRAM. I'M AS YOU KNOW
IT'S VERY COMMON FOR NEW
PROGRAMS- TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
IMPLEMENT TO HAVE UNSPENT
MONEYS EARLY ON. SO AFTER HE
WITHDRAWS THE BASE
AUGMENTATIONS HE HIT THEM
PROPOSES BASS REDUCTION. FOR
THE COLLEGES HE HAS AN 8%
REDUCTION TO APPORTIONMENT. AND
THEN WITH SELECTIVE OTHER
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THE
REDUCTIONS RANGE FROM 10% 258%
FOR THE UNIVERSITY IS THE
GOVERNOR HAS 10% BASE
REDUCTIONS I TO THEIR GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT AND BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITIES HAVE A MIX OF
GENERAL FUND AND STUDENT
TUITION REVENUE THOSE EQUATE TO
ABOUT A 5% REDUCTION IN OUR
COURT. THINKING UNLIKE
PRODUCTIONS FOR THE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES THE MAY
REVISION KEEPS OF FUNDING FOR
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS INTACT
WITH NO PROPOSED REDUCTIONS.
AND THIS APPLIES BOTH TO NEED
BASED PROGRAMS LIKE THE CAL
GRANT AS WELL AS NON NEED BASED
PROGRAMS LIKE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM.
CONSISTENT WITH JANUARY
GOVERNOR PROPOSES NO CHANGES
ARE NO INCREASES IN TUITION.
AND ALSO HE SUCKS NO ENROLLMENT
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
IN FOR THE COLLEGE IT'S THAT'S
A LITTLE DIFFERENT AND NOT HE
HAS THE BASE REDUCTION TO
APPORTIONMENT BUT EXPECT THEM
TO SERVE ABOUT AS MANY STUDENTS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AS THEIR
STERN SERVING NOW. THE LAST
MAJOR COMPONENT OF THE ME
REVISION HIGHER EDUCATION
PACKAGES THE TRIGGER THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT IF THE STATE
WHERE TO GET FOURTEEN BILLION
IN ADDITIONAL- FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDING. THAT WOULD GO TO
HOWEVER SEND ALL OF THESE I'M
ALMOST ALL OF THE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS IT WOULD BE ALL OR
NOTHING ALL OF THE RESTORATIONS
WOULD BE APPLIED FOR NONE OF
THEM. AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
FIGURE MOST OF THE REDUCTIONS
WOULD BE RESTORED AND VIRTUALLY
ALL OF THOSE REDUCTIONS ARE ON
GOING SO EVEN THOUGH THE
FEDERAL RELIEF MONEY IF THAT
MATERIALIZES WILL BE VERY
LIKELY ONE TIME. IT WOULD BE
USING TO SUSTAIN ONGOING
PROGRAM. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
THREE OF THE HAND OUT IT'LL
SHOW YOU ALL OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE PROPOSALS YOU CAN
SEE THE A PORTION MEGA KAT OF A
HUNDRED- I'M SORRY. OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE
MILLION BUT YOU CAN ALSO SEE
SIGNIFICANT CUTS TO ADULT
EDUCATION TIME PERCENT 58% CUT
TO THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
FOUR IT SHOWS- THE REACTIONS
THAT WE HAVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
NAY REVISION FOR THE COLLEGE AS-
WE KNOW THE STATE'S FACING VERY
HARD BUDGET SITUATION WE THINK
THEY'RE ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH OF USING MANY
DIFFERENT BUDGET TOOLS IS
APPROPRIATE. BUT WE THINK THAT
AS A CHURCH WAS MENTIONED IN
THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
MORE STRATEGIC MORE TARGETED
MORE SELECTIVE IN HOW YOU GO
ABOUT ACHIEVING YOUR ADOPTION.
WE ALSO THINK THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE BUDGET
LANDSCAPE TO IDENTIFY SOME
LOTTERY FUNDS THAT YOU COULD
REPURPOSE SOME UNSPENT. ONE
TIME- NINETEEN TWENTY FUNDS
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDS THAT
COULD BE YOUR BEST. I'M WHAT'S
THAT WE THINK WE'VE TRIED TO
IDENTIFY SOME LOWER PRIORITY
PROGRAMS THAT YOU COULD SWAP
OUT WITH CUTS TO APPORTIONMENT
FOR EXAMPLE. WERE ALSO SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
TRIGGER APPROACH AND NOT FOR
THE COLLEGES FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
MONEY DOES MATERIALIZE IT WOULD
NOT ONLY RESTORE THE BASE
REDUCTION OF 8% TO A PORTION
MEN'S BUT ALSO THE COLA. SO THE
STARTING POINT YOU WOULD BE
WORKING FROM NEXT YEAR WOULD BE
EVEN HIGHER THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE PROGRAMMATIC CUTS IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO MIGHT SEEM EVEN
MORE SIGNIFICANT FOR THEIR
FEELINGS TO YOU RIGHT NOW. WE
HAVE TO TURN IT IS THAT YOU
COULD CONSIDER ON PAGE FIVE WE
SHOW THE ALTERNATIVE THAT WE'VE
LAID OUT FOR PORTION THAT. IT
WAS ALSO WAS TO ACHIEVE THE
SAME LEVEL GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
AS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS
A MEMEBER VISION BUT TO ACHIEVE
IT DIFFERENTLY SO THE COMMENTS
ARE THERE JUST FOR YOUR
REFERENCE DOWN THE ROAD BUT IF
YOU FOCUS ON THE DOLLAR
CHANGES. I'M THE PACKAGE WOULD
ELIMINATE ONE NON NEED BASED
PROGRAM. IT WOULD ELIMINATE A
BRIGHT. I'M A COLLEGE THAT WAS
RECENTLY CREATED NOT BY THE
STATE IT WOULD REDIRECT SOME
MONEY THAT CURRENTLY SPORTS
TEAMS TO. EARN FOR THEIR PER.
IN BUT THAT COMES AS AND- IT
WOULD STOP THAT PRACTICE. IT
WAS THE- DESTRUCTION THAT THE
STATE CURRENTLY PLAYS LOTTERY
FUNDS TO ALLOW COLLEGES TO USE
THOSE FUNDS FOR ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY AND RESOURCES
SOMETHING THAT'S OBVIOUSLY HIGH
DEMAND RIGHT NOW. SO TAKING ALL
OF THOSE TARGETED CUTS ACHIEVES
ABOUT HALF THE LEVEL OF SAVINGS
AS AND THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION. THEN WE THINK THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO RE DIRECT
ALREADY EXISTING FEDERAL
RESOURCES SO AT THE GOVERNOR
RIGHT NOW IS USING THE CROWN A
RELIEF FUND AND THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY EDUCATION REALLY FIND
ENTIRELY FOR SCHOOLS. AND WE
THINK YOU COULD CONSIDER USING
A PORTION OF THAT FOR THE
COLLEGES. SO UNDER THIS KIND OF
MORE STRATEGIC APPROACH EVEN IF
THE STATE WERE TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IT WOULD HAVE
RESERVES OR OTHER FEDERAL
RESOURCES THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
USE NEXT YEAR IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO DAMPEN THE
REDUCTION NOT PROGRAMS WILL
FEEL AS THE ECONOMY- AS AS YOU
KNOW THE STATE HAS A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE THAT RIGHT NOW IS
ANTICIPATED TO LAST POTENTIALLY
AS LONG AS TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. PAGE SIX LAYS OUT AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
ON CT. R. THE AIM OF THIS
ALTERNATIVE IS TO ALSO REDIRECT
FUNDS FROM LOWER PRIORITY
PROGRAMS AND UNPROVEN PROGRAMS
TO TRY TO SUPPORT THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM. WHICH IS
THE PROGRAM NOT THE COLLEGES
RECEIVE TO PAY FOR HIGHER C. T.
EQUIPMENT COSTS AN
INSTRUCTIONAL COSTS. SO WITH A
LOT OF FOLKS RIGHT NOW LAID OFF
ATTENTION HE WANTED TO GO BACK
TO THE COLLEGES TO BE RETRAINED
THREE SKILLED THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT COULD HELP THEM DO THAT.
SO W TRY TO REDIRECT MONEY
FROM THESE LOWER PRIORITY AREAS
SO THAT THE STATE COULD IN
STATE SUSTAIN ENROLLMENT. IN
THOSE EACH YEAR COURSES. IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE SEVEN IT SHOWS YOU
ALL OF THE ADJUSTMENTS FOR CSU.
YOU CAN SEE THE A THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT MILLION BASS
REDUCTION FOR EXAMPLE FOR CSU.
ROACHES SIMILAR WITH WITH
TRYING PROPOSALS AND TAKING A
BASS REDUCTION. IF YOU GO TO
PAGE EIGHT YOU CAN SEE THE SAME
APPROACH BEING TAKEN FOR YOU
SEEING WITH THE WITHDRAWAL OF
JANUARY PROPOSALS ON THE 10%
REDUCTION WHICH IN THIS CASE-
IS THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION. I DON'T THE MAIN
PAGE OF THE HANDOUT SO PAGE
NINE I'M SHOWS YOUR REACTION TO
THE MAY REVISION FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES I'M HERE WE THINK
TO THERE'S SOME MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE MORE
TARGETED AND HOW YOU GO ABOUT.
BUILDING THEIR BY JETS. I'M ALL
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS ARE GONNA HAVE A HARD
TIME RIGHT NOW ADJUSTING THEIR
BUDGET SO QUICKLY SUMMER TERM
IS STARTING A COUPLE WEEKS FROM
NOW AND THE ACADEMIC TERM IS
STARTING FOR SOME COMP
CAMPUSES. AS EARLY AS OF LATE
GUEST SO CAMPUS IS ALREADY
HAVING TO DEVELOP COURSE
SCHEDULES TO STAFF. SUCH IT'S
HARD FOR THEM TO BE SUPER
NIMBLE SUPER QUICKLY SO WHAT
KIND DO IT JUST GIVE THEM
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO GIVE
THEM TWENTY TWENTY ONES THAT
THEY CAN PLAN FOR DOCUMENTS
THAT. YOU NEED IT DONE OUT. IT
PAGE UP AND OUT. OUT IN A LOT
OF APPROACH FOR THE UNIVERSE.
AND THE FIRST THING IN IN THE
UP IS TO A REPURPOSE THE MUCH
THE ON SPENT TWENTY NAY TWENTY
AS POSSIBLE SO NORM WHEN THE
STATE ENTERS A RECESSION THE
FIRST THING IT DOES ITS FIRST
OURSE OF ACTION IS TO TRY TO
FIND EVERY ON SPENT DOLLAR THAT
IT CAN. IT SPECIALLY VERY
RESEND THING WHERE THE
PROGRAM'S HAVEN'T GOTTEN UP AND
RUNNING VERY FEW PEOPLE WILL BE
AFFECTED IF THOSE DOLLARS ARE
REPURPOSE TO SUPPORT THE BASED
ON GOING PROGRAM. I SEE MY
RECALL LAST YEAR THE STATE
PROVIDED BOTH THAT UNIVERSITIES
WITH QUITE A BIT OF ONE TIME
MONEY FIRST THE ISSUE IT WAS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
MILLION FOR YOU SEE IT WAS TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN MILLION.
MOST OF THAT MONEY AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE MONEY. AND YOU
MIGHT HAVE HEARD US SAY
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE RECOVERY
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS TO DEAL
WITH UNIVERSITIES MAINTENANCE
ISSUES. BUT IN A RECESSION
PARTICULAR RECESSION THAT CAME
SO QUICKLY AND MIGHT BE SO DEEP
IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT YOU
WANT TO CONSIDER RE PURPOSING
FOR ONGOING PROGRAMS. THIS
WOULD STILL MEAN YOU COULD
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PLAN WITH
THE UNIVERSITIES TO TRY TO DEAL
WITH OUTSTANDING MAINTENANCE
ISSUES. OVER THE LONG RUN.
THERE'S ALSO SOME OPPORTUNITIES
WE THINK THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
USED ONE JANUARY AUGMENT. ONE
TIME PROPOSAL WE IT'S JUST NOT
A PRUDENT TIME TO DO NEW ONE
TIME THINGS. HE ANOTHER THING
YOU MIGHT CONSIDER IS TARGETED
REDUCTIONS SO FIGURE OUT WHERE
WHERE WITHIN THE UNIVERSITIES
MIGHT BE ANOTHER- A PLACE THAT
WOULD HAVE LESS IMPACT ON
DIRECT STUDENT SERVICES
INSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THE BUDGET YEAR. SO
WE JUST ILLUSTRATE SIMPLY SHOW
YOU WHAT A 10% CUT TO USE THESE
THREE STARTS BUDGET WOULD LOOK
LIKE JUST THE STATE GENERAL
FUND. OF FLEXIBLE PORTION OF
THEIR RESEARCH- IF THE STATE
WERE TO TAKE A 10% CUT TO THAT
HOT WHICH EQUATES TO ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION. IT WOULD
STILL HAVE FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN FEDERAL PRIVATE
RESTRICTED IN SPECIAL FUND
RESOURCES FOR RESEARCH WHICH WE
KNOW IS CORE TO THEIR MISSION.
SO THE LAST THING THEN WOULD BE
WORKING WITH THE SEGMENTS TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION TO JOT
DOWN THEIR INTERNAL
UNRESTRICTED RESERVES. AS AN
EFFORT TO PRESERVE ONGOING
PROGRAM. SO WE PENCILLED IN
HERE JUST A STARTING POINT FOR
CSU OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION AND
FOR YOU SEE OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION. BUT THESE WOULD BE
PURPOSEFUL AGREEMENTS WITH THE
STATEMENTS TO BE DRAWING DOWN
RESERVES IN THIS TIME TO BE
SUPPORTING THOSE PROGRAMS. IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. SO THE LAST
POINT IS ARE WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO HAVE REPORTING OR LANGUAGE
ALMOST REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU
DO THAT WOULD HAVE THE SEGMENTS
REPORT BACK TO YOU PERHAPS IN
THE FALL MAYBE BY NOVEMBER.
ABOUT THEIR ENROLLMENTS THEIR
UNRESTRICTED RESERVES THEIR
RESTRICTED RESERVES THEIR
OPERATING EFFICIENCIES THEIR
OPERATING REDUCTIONS AND THEIR
TUITION PLANS AND HOW THEY'RE
AB REDUCTIONS ARE IMPACTING
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS FOR BOTH
WHAT THEY PERCEIVE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO HELP YOU PREPARE
FOR THE FUTURE. OUR PRIMARY
GOAL IN ALL THESE ALTERNATIVES
YOU CAN TAKE THEM AND PART OR
YOU CAN TAKE THEM AND HOLE YOU
CAN TAKE PIECES OF A ONE BUT
NOT THE OTHER BUT THEY'RE ALL
INTENDED TO GIVE YOU A
REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE. FOR YOU
TO CONTEMPLATE. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT-
THEM AND AS WELL AS OUR WHOLE
UNIT WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
STOCK OVER THE COMING FEW DAYS
AND WEEKS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE TRADE OFF AND
WOULD BE. THANKS. OKAY THANK
YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS.
DAN HAD ARE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SOME OF THIS WILL
ECHO THE PRESENTATION PROVIDED
BY MY CALL I GET THE LA L. BUT
I'M GONNA AGAIN WITH A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE NAY
REVISION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
AS WELL AS THE MAJOR SPENDING
PROPOSALS FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THEN HANDED OFF
TO MY COLLEAGUES JENNIFER LOUIS
WHO DISCUSSED THE REMAINDER
FROM THE REVISION PROPOSALS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. IN LIGHT OF
THE COVER NINETEEN. DOING
RECESSION THE MAYOR VISION FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION FOCUSES ON TWO
KEY PRINCIPLES THE CONTINUED
EMPHASIS ON SUSTAINING AND
IMPROVING ACCESS AND EQUITY.
AND A COMMITMENT TO A BALANCED
BUDGET. DESPITE ITS ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS THE ADMINISTRATION
REMAINS COMMITTED TO MAXIMIZING
ACCESS AND EQUITY. THE
ADMINISTRATION US OF THE
STATE'S COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. DO ALL THEY CAN'T
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA IT STUDENTS
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME. TO
THAT END THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED TO ENSURE THAT THE CAL
GRANT AND MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS REMAIN
UNTOUCHED FOR ALL STUDENTS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY. OR PLANNING TO
ATTEND ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
INSTITUTIONS A PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. THE GOAL OF THIS IS
TO ENSURE THE HIGHER EDUCATION
REMAINS AN OPTION FOR STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ECONOMIC
STATUS. ADDITIONALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TO
SEE COLLEGES. AND UNIVERSITIES
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
PROVIDING FULLY ONLINE EDUCATE.
EDUCATION OPTIONS. WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON ENSURING THAT UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENT GROUPS. ARE
ABLE TO ENROLL AND SUCCEED IN
THESE PROGRAMS. ALTHOUGH THIS
IS A TIME OF CONSTRAINED
RESOURCES THE SHIP ONLINE
EDUCATION PROVIDES OPTIONS SUCH
AS THE USE OF COMMON ONLINE
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS.
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION AND
CREDIT FOR PRIOR LEARNING THAT
CAN PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY
AND EFFICIENCY. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT EACH OF THE
SEGMENTS THIS MEETING IS
PRIORITY THE ADMINISTRATION
CALLS ON EACH OF THE SEGMENTS
TO ESTABLISH THIS TO MICHAEL'S
SPECIFYING. THE PERCENTAGE OF
ONLINE COURSES BEING OFFERED IN
THE OF STUDENTS CREDIT. THE
COMPANY BUT COMPETENT BASED THE
EDGE. AND CREDIT BY EXAM.
RESPONSE TO DECLINING ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE STATE NEEDS
TO TAKE SIGNIFICANT STEPS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
BALANCED BUDGET. MOST OF THE
NEW SPENDING PROPOSALS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAVE BEEN
WITHDRAWN AND IN MANY AREAS
SIGNIFICANT FURTHER REDUCTIONS
ARE NECESSARY. I WOULD NOT THAT
FOR SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS
WE'VE INCLUDED LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD RESTORE THE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS. IF SUFFICIENT NEW
FEDERAL FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO.
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN LISTING
SOME OF THE MAJOR NEW PROPOSALS
IN EACH AREA STARTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FIRST AS I PREVIOUSLY
REFERENCED THE MAYOR VISION
WITHDRAWS MOST OF THE NEW
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE TWO NOTABLE
EXCEPTIONS TO THIS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THE PROPOSITION
NINE NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
PROVIDED FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF. AT
THIS POPULATION WILL FACE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC CLIMATE. AND A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND FOR AN ACCOUNTING
POSITION AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. THAT WILL BE ESSENTIAL
IN HELPING THE SYSTEM IN THIS
TIME OF SCARCE RESOURCES.
ADDITIONALLY WE WERE NOT THAT
ALTHOUGH FUNDING HAS BEEN
REMOVED FOR THE DREAMER
RESOURCE THE IS ON. AND FOOD
PANTRIES. THE BILL LANGUAGE HAS
BEEN INCLUDED TO REQUIRE
COLLEGES TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM FUNDS.
ADDITIONALLY ALL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS PROVIDED A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
WITHDRAWN TO REFLECT THE COLOR
0% HOWEVER DUE TO SIGNIFICANT A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE LEVEL AN
OVERALL BUDGETARY REVENUES
ADDITIONAL MEASURES ARE NEEDED
TO HELP PROTECT THE FISCAL
STABILITY OF THE STATE. TO
ADDRESS THIS THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS INCLUDED NECESSARY
REDUCTIONS TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUDGET. AT THE LARGE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED ARE IN A
PORTION IS TO FOR ALL OF THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY POINT ONE
MILLION. FROM CURRENT YEAR OR-
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO THE BUDGET YEAR
FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN APARTMENTS
DEFERRAL OF SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO POINT ONE MILLION. FROM
BUDGET YEAR- TO OF FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TO THE SUBSEQUENT YOUR-
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IN A REDUCTION TO
THE STUDENT CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA. OF 10% WHICHWHEN
COMBINED WITH THE WHEN COMBINED
WITH THE REMOVAL OF THE COLA
TOUGH TOTALING ROUGHLY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS. WE WOULD NOT TO THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES LANGUAGE
SPECIFYING THAT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. IN THIS PROPOSAL WILL
BE SKILLED. SIR REDUCTIONS
NECESSARY TO ACCOMMODATE
REDUCED ESTIMATES OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY GUARANTEE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR INCLUDE.
REDUCTION OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE POINT SIX MILLION.
TO THE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
WHICH WOULD BE THE NEW PRODUCT-
FUNDING- FOR THE PROGRAM AND A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND
SOME ROUGHLY 15% REDUCTIONS FOR
DIFFERENT CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS.
WHICH ARE A SIXTY EIGHT POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION
TO THE STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM. IN
EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION TO THE SYSTEM
SUPPORT CONSOLIDATION. HUNDRED
AND FIFTY REDUCTION TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE A SEVEN POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION TO
THE PART TIME FACULTY
COMPETITION IN OFFICE HOURS
PROGRAMS AND A AND A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR PRODUCTION TO
TOP RIGHT COLLEGE. FINALLY THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES NEW
PIECES OF CRITICAL LANGUAGE THE
HELP TO ENACT THE PREVIOUSLY
SPECIFIED PROPOSALS. THE
MEDICINE ALSO INCLUDES DVR
SECTIONS THAT WOULD CODIFY
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY RATES
ANALYSIS COMPLETED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND
EXCLUDE. OPEN NINETEEN RELATED
COSTS FROM 50% ALL. THIS MAYOR
VISION X. INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL CHANGES BUT THESE ARE
RELATIVELY SMALL AND ARE MEANT
TO REFLECT CHANGES IN REPORTED
WORK LET. WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
JENNIFER.
AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JENNIFER LEE ON BEHALF OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE DAN HUNTER OR
DISCUSSED IN LIGHT OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND DOING
RECESSION. THERE A REVISION
REFLECTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EMPHASIS. ON SUSTAINING ACCESS
AND EQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND A COMMITMENT TO A BALANCED
BUDGET. OVER HOPE PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE NAY REVISION
PROPOSALS TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE DO NOT HELP
FOR INSTANCE IT COMMISSION. AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY.
EXCLUDING ANIME REVISION IS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ENABLE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE CALIFORNIA MANY COLLEGES TO
USE RESTRICTED BALANCES. FROM
PARKING FEES UNIVERSITY
ENTERPRISE AND OTHER ARTILLERY
ACTIVITIES EXCEPT LOTTERY
BALANCES TO COVER KOPEN
NINETEEN RELATED IMPACTS. AND
KOBE NINETEEN RELATED REVENUE
LOSSES. THE LANGUAGE WOULD
REQUIRE THE CSU AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES I
REQUEST THE UC THE FIRST USE
ANY RESTRICTED FUND BALANCES TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS TO
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. THAT
PREDOMINATELY SUPPORT UNDER
REPRESENTED IS DOING ACCESS TO
AS A SUCCESS AT A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY AND TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER STUDENTS ANNUALLY SIR IN
ALL MY COURSES AND PROGRAMS. IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL ALSO PURSUE STATUTORY
CHANGES AUTHORIZING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. TO
TEMPORARILY RE DIRECT SAVINGS.
FROM DEBT SERVICING TOWARDS
SUMMER USES. THEY MAY REVISION
MAINTAIN SEVERAL HOLES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
INCLUDING ELEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
FOR UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE TO SUPPORT CURRENT
OPERATIONS ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ON GOING DOWN ARE FINE
FOR A UCSF SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
FRESNO BRANCH CAMPUS TO SUPPORT
AN EXISTING UCSF UC MERCED
PARTNERSHIP. AND FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR AN
ANIMAL SHELTER GRANT
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT. IN
ADDITION THE ME REVISION
WITHDRAWS THE REMAINING
PROPOSALS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR BOTH UCSC ISSUES
INCLUDING THE 5% FACE
AUGMENTATIONS I WERE PROPOSED
FOR EACH SEGMENT. THE FOUR
MILLION FOR YOU SEE AND SIX
MILLION FIRST ISSUE THAT
REFLECT A LIMITED TIME FUNDING
FOR SUMMER FINANCIAL AID AND
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT. THE MAY REVISION
ALSO PROPOSES FURTHER
ADJUSTMENTS AND MAKES THEM
CONTINGENT ON FEDERAL FUNDING.
UNLESS AND UNTIL SUFFICIENT
INCREASES AND FEDERAL SUPPORT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR PROGRAM
RESTORATION. THESE REDUCTIONS
ARE NECESSARY TO BALANCE THE
STATE BUDGET. THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S MAIN
GENERAL FUND ITEM AND THREE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT MILLION
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. EACH REFLECTING A
10% REDUCTION. THIRTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
OTHER GENERAL FUND ITEM FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. EASY PATH AND
THE DIVISION OF AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES. AND THE FOUR
MILLION FOR YOU SEE AND SIX
MILLION FOR CITIES ONE TIME
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE OF COMPLETION
PROGRAM. THE MINISTER CAN
EXPECT THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
MANY COLLEGES WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOWARD MAXIMIZING ACCESS
AND EQUITY DESPITE THE
CONSTRAINT RESOURCES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CO THE NINETEEN
RECESSION. TO THIS AD AT THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS THAT
THESE REDUCTIONS IN FUNNY WILL
NOT HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON LOW INCOME. UNDER
REPRESENTED FOR DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. MOVING NOW TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE THE
COMMISSION. AND FINANCIAL AID.
THEY MAY REVISION MAINTAIN ALL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS FOR
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. TO SUPPORT
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. SEVERAL
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE INCLUDING AN INCREASE OF
SIX HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO OFFSET A DECREASE IN
AVAILABLE TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE
FOR NEEDY FAMILIES
REIMBURSEMENT. OKAY ED HAVE.
AND AS WELL AS TIME. UP AND THE
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES-
REDUCTIONS- FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY PROPOSALS. I'M
WITHOUT WILL CONCLUDE MY
PRESENTATION AND MY COLLEAGUES
ARE AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU WILL
CERTAINLY COME BACK TO YOU IN A
BIT- NOW WE'RE GONNA ASK OUR
SEGMENTS TO GIVE US AN OVERVIEW
OF THE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL ON
WHERE WE'RE AT AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
YOU YOU SEE CSU COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND STUDENT COMMISSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ALL
I'M SAYING UPPER TENANTS WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ALL. THE SERGEANTS SHOULD HAVE
PASSED OUT OF HAND OUT FOR YOU
THAT HAS A BLUE COVER THAT I
WILL BE SPEAKING TO TODAY AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
LA- HAVE DISCUSSED THE STATE IS
FACING SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF
REVENUE FROM COVERT NINETEEN.
AND UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
NO EXCEPTION. THE UNIVERSITY
MAKES TO ASKS OF THE STATE. TO
APPROVE A BUDGET THAT MAINTAINS
TO UNIVERSITY STATE GENERAL
FUND ALLOCATION AT THE LEVELS
PROVIDED. IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND TO THE
GREATEST DEGREE POSSIBLE AS THE
STATE RECEIVES FEDERAL FUNDS IT
CONSIDERED UNIVERSITY. AS A
STRONG INVESTMENT. IT'S LIKE TO
DETAILS UNIVERSITIES COVERED
NINETEEN RELATED FINANCIAL
LOSSES THROUGH APRIL THIRTIETH
A TOTAL OF NEARLY ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. IN
EXPENDITURES AND LOST REVENUES.
AT WORLD'S LARGEST PUBLIC
RESEARCH UNIVERSITY OUR
ACADEMIC HEALTH CENTERS ARE
TREATING PATIENTS. OUR
RESEARCHERS ARE SEEKING THERAPY
CENTER VACCINE. WE ARE
PROVIDING OUR TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITH REMOTE CONSTRUCTION. AND
CONTINUING TO EMPLOY OUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. THE UNIVERSITY HAS
ACCESS. OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION IN FEDERAL
SUPPORT PROVIDED BY THE CARE
SUCKED ONE HALF OF WHICH GOES
TO CAMPUSES AND THE OTHER HALF
IS DIRECT EMERGENCY GRANTS TO
STUDENTS. THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION THE
CAMPUSES WILL RECEIVE COVERS
ONLY A FRACTION OF THE COST
ATTRIBUTABLE TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN. UC'S ACADEMIC HEALTH
CENTERS HAVE RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION TO DATE IN CARE
SECTOR FUNDING FOR HOSPITALS.
AGAIN THIS WILL NOT FULLY
COVERED THE FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION IN LOST REVENUES
FROM CANCEL SURGERIES AND OTHER
MEDICAL CARE. THE UNIVERSITY
WILL ALSO TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE
OF FEMUR REIMBURSEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PANDEMIC
RELATED COSTS. BUT FEMA
REIMBURSE BUT REVERSES ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES AND NOT LOST
REVENUES. DO THE COLBERT
NINETEEN IMPACTS CAMPUSES HAVE
LOST FLEXIBILITY WITH FUNDING.
WE HAVE COSTS IN EVERY AREA OF
OUR OPERATIONS AND WE DON'T GET
NO WHERE THE BOTTOM IS. HI
THERE PRIOR ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS
THE UNIVERSITY HAD OPTIONS FOR
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL BORROWING
THE CUSHION PRODUCTIONS AND NOW
THAT OPTION FOR BORROWING IS
NOT AVAILABLE IN THE SAME WAY.
WE ARE NOW FAR MORE CONSTRAINED
WITHOUT CONTEXT IN MIND I ASK
YOU TO TURN TO SLIDE THREE. THE
CHART ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
SLIDE THREE SHOWS THE CORE
FUNDS FOR STUDENTS. EACH BAR ON
THE CHART PRESENTS A TOTAL
EXPENDITURE PER STUDENT
ALTHOUGH THE TOTAL AMOUNT. MOST
RECENT YEARS. OF SHOWS THE
FINANCIAL AID OUR RETIREMENT
PROGRAM CONTRIBUTIONS AND
UNIVERSITIES DEBT SERVICE. ARE
TAKING UP AN INCREASINGLY LARGE
AMOUNT OF CAMPUS FUNDING. THIS
MEANS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
DOLLARS PER STUDENT ARE NOW
ABOUT THE SAME AS THEY WERE IN
TWENTY TEN. WE ALSO BASED ON
CERTAIN REGARDING OUR
INTERNATIONAL ENROLLMENT ARE
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS
CONTRIBUTE NEARLY ONE POINT
THREE BILLION THE CAMPUS BUDGET
THROUGH SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION
PAID PAY. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT KNOW IF ARE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO RETURN
OR IF THEY WILL CHOOSE TO
RETURN TO THEIR STUDIES IN THE
FALL. THIS COULD IMPACT THE
FUNDS THE CAMPUSES HAVE TO RELY
UPON TO EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS.
IN THIS CASE THIS IS THE
CONTEXT IN WHICH YOU ARE ASKED
TO CONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISED RECOMMENDATION OF A 10%
REDUCTION THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE UNIVERSITY ONLY
HAS THREE POSSIBLE WAYS OF
DEALING WITH REVENUE LOSSES.
CUTTING EXPENDITURES INCREASING
REVENUES ARE USING RESERVES.
CAMPUS CORE FUND RESERVES ARE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO DEAL WITH
THESE UNEXPECTED COSTS. OF I
ASK YOU TO PLEASE TURN TO SLIDE
FOR TO SEE HOW THE UNIVERSITY
HAS INITIALLY DEALT WITH THESE
UNEXPECTED EXPENDITURES AND
LOST REVENUES. COLLECTIVELY ALL
UC CHANCELLORS OF PRESENT
APPALLED TANO ANNOUNCED ON
APRIL SECOND THAT THERE WOULD
BE NO COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
LAYOFFS. FOR CAREER EMPLOYEES
THROUGH THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. THIS DECISION WAS MADE
TO GIVE PEACE OF MIND TO OUR
VALUED EMPLOYEES AS THE THIRD
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE STATE
UC'S ACTIONS IN KEEPING PEOPLE
EMPLOYED HAS POSITIVELY
IMPACTED LOCAL ECONOMIES.
HOWEVER CONTINUED TO PAY
EMPLOYEES WHEN MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS OF OUR REVENUE HAVE
EXPERIENCED TREMENDOUS LOSSES
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE WITHOUT
SUSTAINED. STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS. SO FAR TO CONTAIN COSTS
AND CUT EXPENDITURES UC HAS
TAKEN A NUMBER OF STEPS THESE
INCLUDE A SYSTEM WIDE FOR USE
ON SALARIES FOR NON REPRESENTED
STAFF. A SYSTEM WIDE FOR USE ON
SALARY SCALES FOR NON STUDENT
ACADEMIC OF APPOINTEES A
VOLUNTARY PAY CUT OF 10% FOR
CURRENT CHANCELLOR SENT
PRESIDENT. ELIMINATING NON
ESSENTIAL TRAVEL AND
RENEGOTIATING PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE AGREEMENTS. SLIDE FIVE
SHOWS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL REDUCES
UNIVERSITIES BUDGET BY 10% OR
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
MILLION FROM THE NINETEEN
TWENTY FUNDING LEVEL. WE
BELIEVE THAT PRODUCTION SO
UNIVERSITIES BASED BUDGET
COMBINED WITH INCREASES COST IN
LOST REVENUES THE UNIVERSITY
EXPERIENCE IS EXPERIENCING WILL
HAVE A NEGATIVE ABILITY. IMPACT
OUR ABILITY TO DELIVER
INSTRUCTION CONDUCT RESEARCH
AND CARE FOR PATIENTS. WITH
THEREFORE REQUEST THAT YOU HOLD
THE UNIVERSITIES BASED BUDGET
FLAT FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY. TO THE BUDGET
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE ALSO
SEEK YOUR ASSISTANCE IN
RECEIVING AS MUCH FEDERAL
FUNDING COMING TO CALIFORNIA'S
POSSIBLE WE REQUEST THIS
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY IS GOING
TO BE IN ROLLING ADDITIONAL
STEPS THIS FALL. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THESE
INCOMING CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES RECEIVED THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE. IN
PRIOR RECESSIONS UNIVERSITY
RAISE REVENUES WHICH HELP
COUNTER LOSSES IN STATE GENERAL
FUND TO MAINTAIN ACCESS.
AFFORDABILITY AND QUALITY. BUT
IN THIS COVERT INDUCED
RECESSION WE KNOW THAT MULTIPLE
REVENUE SOURCES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED ON ARE NOT AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS STAFF
AND FACULTY. THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE ALSO CONTINUES TO MAKE
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN
MEDICAL EDUCATION INCLUDING
ELEVEN POINT THREE MILLION FOR
UC'S UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. UNIVERSITY CONTINUES
TO REQUEST TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR THE UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE BECAUSE THE SCHOOL IS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO EXPAND
MEDICAL EDUCATION IN A REGION
THAT HAS BEEN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED FOR FAR TOO LONG.
AND THAT CONCLUDES THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PORTION OF MY PRESENTATION I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO MAKE A
STATEMENT FOR UC HASTINGS. THIS
IS ON BEHALF OF THE HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW OF THE CFO
DAVID STEWART. HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF THE LAW FOUNDED IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IS A STRONG AND
RESILIENT INSTITUTION DEDICATED
TO FULFILLING ITS PUBLIC
MISSION. THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
FISCAL CARNAGE COST AND TO BE
COST BY COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS OF A STARK
PROPORTIONS. HASTINGS VALUES
THIS OF ITS AFFILIATION WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
HASTINGS DOES NOT BENEFIT FROM
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH OF OUR
COMPATRIOTS IN CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION. WE
WILL PERSEVERE TO MANAGE
THROUGH THESE DIFFICULT TIMES
AND LOOK FORWARD TO BETTER ONCE
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS RYAN
STORE I AM THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. I THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PROVIDE
SEE ISSUES COMMENTS ON THE CSU
OUTLOOK. AND EBAY REVISION.
I'LL SPEAK TO A PROPOSED CUT IN
A PROPOSED FISCAL FLEXIBILITY
PROPOSAL THE REVISION. SO START
OFF THOUGH AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR THIS YEAR SHE WAS ON
VERY STRONG FOOTING- THE C.
ISSUES FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATE
FOR FIRST TIME STUDENTS
INCREASED. TO TWENTY SEVEN
POINT 5% UP FROM NINETEEN POINT
3% SINCE THE LAUNCH DATE OF
GRADUATION ISSUE OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THREE GRADUATED- TOOTH- TWENTY
THOUSAND MORE UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS OR ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS- THAN
JUST FIVE YEARS AGO. AND WE
MADE PROGRESS IN ENSURING THAT
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF WERE
BEING. EIGHT FAIR AND
COMPETITIVE WAGES. WELL OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE CHANGED IN
THE STATE IS NOW IN AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN WE CONTINUE TO BE
FOCUSED ON OUR MISSION. AND
SERVING OUR STUDENTS AND
CALIFORNIA AS BEST AS WE CAN.
CERTAINLY WE UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION ECHO BED HAS USHERED
IN A NEW FISCAL REALITY. AND
VERY UNFORTUNATELY EIGHT LIKELY
PROLONG STATE BUDGET CRISIS.
TURNING TO THE PROPOSALS- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS A
THREE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR ON GOING BUDGET
REDUCTION. THAT IS A AS YOU'VE
HEARD A 10% REDUCTION TO OUR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION. A
FOR PERSPECTIVE THAT IS THE
QUILT AT THAT IS EQUIVALENT TO
TWO TIMES ALL OF THE ON GOING
MONEY DEDICATED SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN TO SEE ISSUES
GRADUATION ISSUED OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. HI THIS POTENTIAL
REDUCTION IS CLEARLY FORMIDABLE.
MOREOVER THE ACTUAL IMPACT TO
THE C. ISSUE BUDGET IS MORE
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE WE HAVE
CLOSE TO ONE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OF MORE COSTS IN THE
BUDGET THAT ARE NOT FUNDED FOR
THE FOR THE NEXT YEAR. OF THAT
HUNDRED WE BELIEVE ABOUT FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF THIS IS FOR
ON GOING MANDATORY COSTS FOR
SUCH THINGS AS HEALTH CARE. AND
PENSION RATE INCREASES.
ADDITIONALLY THE OTHER 50% WE
COULD EASILY SPEND ON. A ONE
TIME CODE RELATED COSTS TO GET
LIKE CLEANING INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY ADDITIONAL OVERTIME
AND STAFF COSTS. THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION MINIMIZE THE
REDUCTION TO OUR BASE
OPERATIONS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
I WANT POSSIBLE PATH IS TO
ADOPT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
ALTERNATIVE WHICH SWEEPS
UNSPENT CURRENT YOUR MONEY'S
AND LESSONS THE REDUCTION BY
THE SAME ABOUT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. WELL THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
POTENTIAL CUT TO THE C. ISSUE
IS DAUNTING. WE LEARNED FROM
THE GREAT RECESSION AND HAVE A
NUMBER OF TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT ON OUR
STUDENTS. FACULTY AND ON OUR
STAFF. THE CSU IS PRUDENTLY
GROWN RESERVES TO MEET CERTAIN
STRATEGIC GOALS. ONE OF WHICH
IS SPENT PREPARATION FOR
POSSIBLE ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY.
THIS ISSUE HAS DRAWN UPON THESE
RESERVES TO MAINTAIN OPERATIONS
AND PROGRAMS IMPACTED BY COBIT
NINETEEN. AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO. CLEARLY THE USE OF
RESERVES WHICH ARE ONE TIME
FUNDS CANNOT BE A SOLUTION. BUT
THEY ARE A VALUABLE ASSET THEY
COULD BE UTILIZED UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS OTHER RESOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE. OUR CAMPUSES ARE ALL
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL CARES ACT. WHICH TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THE COSTS OF
REVENUE LOSSES DUE TO A COVERT
NINETEEN. AND I LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT WE DID AN ANALYSIS OF
COSTS. TO DATE THROUGH THE
SPRING TERM AND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE COMBINED. COST BECAUSE
A CO BID AND REVENUE LOSSES
RELATED TO- SUCH THINGS AS
HAVING TO CLOSE OUR STUDENT
HOUSING EARLY HAVING EMPTY
PARKING LOTS. THE GRAND TOTAL
IMPACT IS APPROXIMATE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IN APRIL OF THIS ISSUE
IMPLEMENTED A HIRING CHILL. AND
REDUCED NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL-
BOTH OF WHICH WILL SAVE MANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. SO WITH ALL THESE
TOOLS IN MIND WE ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE THE CSU
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY. IS BEING
ABLE TO OPERATIONALIZE THE
pSUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S REVISION
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
SYSTEM TO USE RESTRICTED SEE
ISSUE FUNDS CROSS UNIVERSITY.
TO ADDRESS A CUTE COBIT RELATED
IMPACTS AND REVENUE LOSSES. WE
NEED FLEXIBILITY AS WE ENTER
THESE TOUGH FINANCIAL TIMES.
AND THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ENSURE
THAT IF NEEDED WE WILL HAVE THE
FINAL TOOL NECESSARY TO MAKE
SURE. WE ARE ABLE TO MITIGATE-
IMPACTS TO STUDENTS TO OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF. PLEASE
BUDGET HEARINGS AT DO NOT
DIVERT AND MANY OF OUR SELF
FUNDED STUDENT SERVICES. THAT
ARE ESSENTIAL FOR STUDENTS
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE THOSE ARE
THINGS LIKE STUDENTS CENTERS
WHERE STUDENTS CONGREGATE STUDY
HOST MEETINGS AND LISTEN TO
GUEST SPEAKERS. IT'S ALSO
INCLUDES STUDENT HOUSING AND
DINING SO STUDENTS CAN LIVE ON
CAMPUS WHICH IS OF PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE FOR OUR CAMPUSES ARE
LOCATED IN AREAS. THAT HAVE
LIMITED STUDENT HOUSING
CAPACITY. A PARKING PROGRAMS.
ARE ALSO PART OF THIS CATEGORY
THOSE ARE TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS LIVE OFF CAMPUS AND
NEED A CAR TO ENSURE THEY CAN
GET TO THE CLASSES. AND THEIR
JOBS AND HAVE A PLACE TO PARK.
INSTANT HEALTH CENTERS WHERE
STUDENTS ARE GUARANTEED A LEAST
MINIMUM ACCESS TO BASIC HEALTH
SERVICES ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
STUDENTS WHO LACK HEALTH
INSURANCE. SO THESE ARE A
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS THAT WERE
CREATED BY STATE LAW MANY YEARS
AGO IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT THEY PROVIDE
TO STUDENTS. THESE SELF FUNDED
PROGRAMS DO NOT RECEIVE GENERAL
FUND SPORT INSTEAD THEY ARE
SUPPORTED BY STATE FEES. BUT DO
TO COPE IN NINETEEN LARGELY
EMPTING OUR CAMPUSES. THESE
SELF FUNDED- STUDENT SERVICES
HAVE EXPERIENCED THEIR OWN
FISCAL CRISES. ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING THE RIGHT THING BY
PROPOSING THAT FUNDS COULD BE
TRANSFERRED BETWEEN THESE
FUNCTIONS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
REMAIN SOLVENT. WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE USING THIS TOOL
IMMEDIATELY BUT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN CASE IT
BECOMES NECESSARY IN THE COMING
YEARS. AS WE LOOK TO THE FALL
AND THE FUTURE HANDFUL OF
ITEMS- YOU SHOULD KEEP IN MIND.
FIRST THE CHANCELLOR- RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THAT ARE PLANNING
APPROACH WILL RESULT IN CC
COURSES PRIMARILY BEING
DELIVERED VIRTUALLY. FOR THE
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TERM. WHAT
WHAT WITH LIMITED EXCEPTIONS
FOR IN PERSON ACTIVITIES THAT
CANNOT BE DELIVERED VIRTUALLY.
THERE WILL BE HYBRID APPROACHES
AND THERE WILL BE VERY ABILITY
ACROSS THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES DUE TO SPECIFIC
CONTEXT AND CIRCUMSTANCES. A
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS PREDICT
WAVES OF INFECTIONS IN LATE
FALL TWENTY TWENTY AND EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IF YOU WERE
IN. IN A FACE TO FACE MODALITY
WE WOULD LIKELY HAVE TO SWITCH
TO A VIRTUAL FORMAT. AND THAT
WOULD COMPROMISE RIGOROUS
STANDARDS IN SAFETY AS WELL AS
WELFARE. SECOND FOR THE FUTURE
AS I NOTED EARLIER THE
UNIVERSITY IS MORE THAN JUST
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT SUPPORTS
INCLUDE STATE SIDE STOOD SPORTS
LIKE HEALTH CENTERS. HOUSING
PARKING STUDENTS CENTERS- UP.
TO SOMEBODY'S PROGRAM AREAS ARE
UNCHARACTERISTICALLY
INSIGNIFICANT FISCAL DISTRESS-
BECAUSE STUDENTS EMPLOYEES OF
THE PUBLIC ARE LARGELY ABSENT
FROM THE CAMPUSES. IN THESE
CHALLENGES COULD NEGATIVELY
IMPACT OTHER AREAS OF THE
UNIVERSITY THAT HASN'T HAPPENED
YET- BUT WE ARE WORKING TO
AVOID THAT. BUT WE BUT BE AWARE
THAT IT COULD BECOME A SERIOUS
CHALLENGES FUTURE. THIRD OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATIONHAS TO
BE A PRIORITY IN THE STATE NOW
INTO THE FUTURE. REMEMBER THE
SEA ISSUE IS THE LARGEST FOUR
YEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN THE
COUNTRY. AND HALF OF ALL THE
DEGREES OF THIS STATE. NEED TO
KEEP AT THAT ALL THE NEW
DEGREES THE STATE NEEDS TO KEEP
THE STATE MOVING FORWARD
ORIGINATE OUT OF THE SEA ISSUE.
ARE THOSE YOUR FUTURE TEACHERS
HERE NURSES YOUR SITE TEST YOUR
AGRICULTURAL EXPERTS ALL THAT
WE RELIED VERY HEAVILY THESE
DAYS. FOURTH AND FINALLY- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FULFILL OUR
MISSION TO CALIFORNIA. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A BEACON OF
OPPORTUNITY. SOCIAL MOBILITY IN
THE GOOD TIMES AND NOT SO GOOD
TIMES- THAT ARE AMONG US APART
US TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NOW. ARE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REPRESENTED.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THOSE THAT
NEVER AT BY SINCE RECALLS
FINANCE AND FACILITIES
PLANNING- AND I BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT I'VE NEVER BEEN PROUDER TO
WORK IN REPRESENT WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
I'M AS EVIDENCED BY THEIR
EFFORTS IN THE RESPONSE TO COPE
IN NINETEEN AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE COMMUNITIES HAVE FACE.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
TOUGH BUDGET THIS IS NOT WHAT
YOU WANTED TO DELIVER TO OUR
TWO POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS
BUT IN THE LESS- AT STATE
LEADERS- AS YOU PLAN AND SET
PASSED TO THE RECOVERY FROM
KOBE NINETEEN WE ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER AND PRIORITIZE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. AND RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT WE PLAYED
ALREADY AND WILL CONTINUE TO
AND THE RESPONSE AND THE
PIVOTAL ROLE THAT WE WILL HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY. TEN
YEARS AGO CUTS THE CALIFORNIA
IN COLLEGE TRAINS. INTO DRASTIC
DECLINE IN ACCESS CUTTING
UPWARDS OF SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS FROM HIGHER EDUCATION
MANY OF WHOM NEVER CAME BACK.
THAT TRANSLATED DIRECTLY INTO
HIS STORE STATES WORK FORCE AND
WIDE IN THE CALIFORNIA'S DEGREE
GAP. HUH THE GREATEST RISK THAT
WE NOW FACE IS THAT THESE CUTS
WILL. WILL LIMIT OUR PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE TOWARDS
EQUITABLE SUCCESS IN SOME OF
THE GOALS OUTLINED IN THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS WE CANNOT
ALLOW HISTORY TO REPEAT ITSELF
AND MUST RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
CUTS WILL NOT BE
INCONSEQUENTIAL. AT THE LOWEST
FUNDED HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
THE LARGEST AND THE AND THE
NATION YET MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
FOR EQUITY IN ACCESS WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT DEEP CUTS WILL
EVENTUALLY REACH A BREAKING
POINT. SO IN THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES WE ASK FOR FLEXIBILITY TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT ON OUR
COLLEGES AND THE STUDENTS THAT
THEY SERVE. BEFORE I ADDRESSED
THE PROPOSAL SPECIFICS- I WANT
TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT AND CALIFORNIA COMEY
COLLEGES RESPONSE. THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES HAVE- AND
CONTINUE TO TRAIN- CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST RESPONDERS TRAINING AND
EDUCATING TWO HUNDRED OR-
TWENTY THOUSAND FIRST
RESPONDERS AND HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS EVERY YEAR. TO
ASSIST THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE IN CULVER NINETEEN WITH
DONATED AND PROVIDED HUNDRED
AND FORTY VENTILATORS AND OUR-
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS HAVE GOTTEN
TO WORK MANY OF THEM HAVE
DONATED THOUSANDS OF PIECES OF
PROTECTIVE PERSONAL EQUIPMENT
TO LOCAL HOSPITALS AND CLINICS.
AND ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
PROGRAMS HAVE CREATED FACE
SHIELDS USING THREE D. PRINTERS
TO FULFILL THE NEEDS AT LOCAL
HOSPITALS. OUR CAREER PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO TRAIN THE CRITICAL
INDUSTRY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SECTORS THAT HAVE BEEN OUTLINED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
FACE MANY CHALLENGES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD OUR OVERALL COPING
NINETEEN RELATED COSTS HAVE
INCREASED BY TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO INCREASE EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. KERR'S ACT
UNFORTUNATELY WILL NOT BE
ENOUGH EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
OF OUR STUDENTS WERE ARBITRATOR
ARBITRARILY EXCLUDED FROM
KERRY'S ACT BASED ON THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DEFINITION OF WHO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR EMERGENCY GRANTS. AND WHILE
WE'RE SUPPORTING OUR COLLEGES
AND EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR FREE
MY REIMBURSEMENT NONETHELESS
OUR COSTS WILL INCREASE AND WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT
STUDENT PROGRAMS. AND SO THEN
WE TURN TO YOU- AS A PARTNER IN
RECOVERY AND TO REMIND YOU THAT
OUR PROGRAMS PROVIDE THE
LARGEST WORKFORCE TRAINING IN
THE NATION. WE ARE THE BACKBONE
OF CALIFORNIANS WORKFORCE ARE
NIMBLE PROGRAMS- AND SURE THAT
WE CAN BE ADAPTED TO THE FUTURE
WORK FORCE AND ANY EMERGING- A
CONDOM USE THAT ARE BOTH
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE. WE ALSO
PROVIDE A PATH TO RE ENTRY TO
ANYONE AS OPEN ACCESS AND WE
WILL DO WHAT WE CAN TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN PRESERVE ACCESS
AND- PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
FALLING PREY TO FOR PROFITS
THAT WOULD WILL. I'M TO THEM IN
THEIR TIME OF HONOR ABILITY. SO
LET ME SHARE ABOUT THE PROBE
THE PROPOSAL SPECIFIC TO THE
MAY REVISION. I WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR EMPHASIZING
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION AND
X. BUT I DEVELOPMENT OF SHORT
TERM CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THESE WILL HELP US PUT
CALIFORNIANS TO WORK AND ENSURE
THAT OUR PROGRAMS AGAIN ARE
ALIGNED WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC NEEDS. WE THANK FOR A
WE THANK THE ADMINISTRATION OF
FOR INCLUDING FLEXIBILITY FOR
COSTS RELATED TO COPE IN
NINETEEN OUTSIDE OF THE 50% LAW.
AND WE SUPPORT- THE SENTIMENT
TO MAINTAIN ACCESS BUT AGAIN
ASKED THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE CUTS WILL BE
CONSEQUENTIAL. I THEIR SYSTEM
SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED ALIGNMENT
GREATER COORDINATION
ELIMINATION OF SILOS AND
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL AND MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY OF
STATUTORY SET ASIDES SO WE
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THAT AS
WELL. AND THEN WE APPRECIATE RE
PURPOSING OF BY DOWNS FOR
PENSION LIABILITY SO THAT WE
CAN REDUCE DISTRICTS EMPLOYER
COSTS BY 2% THAT WILL FURTHER
ELIMINATE- MORE CUTS TO
PROGRAMS. LASTLY THEY AT. THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ICLUDED BE APPRECIATIVE
OF THOSE SINCE THEY WILL KEEP
CALIFORNIANS WORKING. NOW WHEN
WE DISCUSS SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT ARE DEEPLY CONCERNING- FOR
THE- ME BEGIN BY SHARING THAT
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS CUTS THAT ARE PROPOSED-
BOTH IN I. IN DEFERRALS
APPORTIONMENT CUTS AND- AND IN
LOST REVENUE EQUATE TO ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMPARISON THAT'S
EQUIVALENT IN OF THE CUTS THAT
WE RECEIVED IN THE FIVE YEARS
OF THE GREAT RECESSION ALL
ABSORBED IN ONE YEAR.
REDUCTIONS TO STRONG WORK FORCE
LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS WORKING AND RE
EMPLOYEE AND RE ENGAGE THOSE
THAT LOSE THEIR JOBS DURING.
THIS TRAGIC TIME AND THEN THE
CUTS TO STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM ARE
DISHEARTENING GIVEN THE FACT
HE'S BEEN THE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE COLLEGES HAVE
TURN TO. WHEN OTHER SOURCES OF
RESOURCES WERE NOT AVAILABLE TO
HELP THE DIRECT NEEDS OF
STUDENTS. INSTEAD WE WANT TO
PROVIDE SOME SUGGESTIONS AND
OTHER APPROACHES THAT CAN BE
TAKEN. FOR EXAMPLE WE WOULD AT
ADVICE OR RECOMMEND CONSIDERING
AND REVISITING THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM LOCAL AND
REGIONAL SPLIT TO ENABLE MORE
RESOURCES TO REMAIN WITH LOCAL
PROGRAMS BUT STILL ALLOWING
REGIONS TO PLAN- AND SERVE
THEIR ECONOMIES. WE ASK THAT
YOU WORK WITH US TO IDENTIFY
NEEDED FLEXIBILITY EASE IN
AREAS SUCH AS LOTTERY FUNDS AND
OTHER- SOURCES THAT CAN
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF THESE
CUTS ON OUR STUDENTS. AND WHILE
NOT CONVENTIONAL BUT STILL
ALLOWED. WE ASK THAT YOU DIRECT
NON PROP NINETY RESOURCES TO
OUR COLLEGES- TO PREVENT
FURTHER LEARNING LOSS AND
FUTURE WORKFORCE LOSSES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH
YOU TO GET MORE FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL. RECOGNIZE
OUR EFFORTS IN THE RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU LESLIE WE HAVE A REPRESENT
HIM FOR THEM WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TO NEED COMMISSION.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS FOR INVITING THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
MY NAME IS JULIA BLAIR I'M AND
TERM DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE COMMISSION.
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS CREATED GREAT UNCERTAINTY
FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
IF THEY MAKE PLANS FOR THE
UPCOMING ACADEMIC YEAR.
STUDENTS ARE REELING FROM THE
MERRY OUT OF CHALLENGES BECAUSE
BY THIS CRISIS INCLUDING HOW
THEY WILL PAY FOR COLLEGE. LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHO ALREADY
STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR COLLEGE ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
DROPPING OUT BECAUSE OF JOB
LOSS AND FINANCIAL INSTABILITY.
THE STUDENT EIGHT COMMISSION
WHICH ADMINISTERS THE STATE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS IS
COMMITTED TO SERVING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS IN THE WAKE
OF COVERT NINETEEN. AND
THROUGHOUT THE ECONOMIC CRISIS.
WE BELIEVE THAT FINANCIAL AID
HELPS KEEP STUDENTS IN COLLEGE
AT A TIME WHEN OUR STATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WILL DEPEND
ON INCREASINGTHE NUMBER OF
COLLEGE GRADUATES IN CALIFORNIA.
TO ASSIST OUR STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS THE
COMMISSION IS EXPANDING ITS
COMMUNICATIONS AND OUTREACH TO
CURRENT AND PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS. TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THAT FINANCIAL AID
THE PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR TUITION
AND BASIC NEEDS IT'S STILL
AVAILABLE TO THEM. MAKING EVERY
EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO TRANSFER
STUDENTS WHO STILL HAVEN'T TOLD
SEPTEMBER SECOND TO APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. WE ARE USING
EMAIL WEB IN OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
AND OUR WEBSITE. TO ENSURE
STUDENTS HAVE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION ON FINANCIAL AID.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
COLLABORATING WITH OUR
INSTITUTIONAL PARTNERS TO
RESPOND QUICKLY TO AN
ANTICIPATED UP TECH IN
FINANCIAL AID APPEALS BY
STUDENTS TO ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE SUDDENLY
CHANGED AS A RESULT OF COVERT
NINETEEN CLOSURES AND LAYOFFS.
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO WE WERE
POISED TO MOVE FORWARD IN
PURSUING CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION WHEN COLBERT
NINETEEN CHANGE THE WORLD AS WE
KNOW IT. THE COMMISSION QUICKLY
PIVOTED AND BEGAN FOCUSING ON
SUPPORTING STUDENTS MUST
IMMEDIATE AND BASIC NEEDS. WELL
COVERED NINETEEN HAVE PUT A
PAUSE ON CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO IMPLEMENTING THE
STRUCTURAL POLICY FRAMEWORK
EVEN WITHOUT NEW FUNDING AS
SOON AS REASONABLY POSSIBLE.
WITH WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY JOSE
MEDINA AND SENATOR CONNIE LEIVA
AND MANY OTHERS FOR SUPPORTING
THESE MODERNIZATION EFFORTS TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
STUDENT NEEDS. REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISED PROPOSAL
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO START OUT
BY SAYING THAT THE COMMISSION
APPRECIATES THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO MAINTAINING
STRONG FINANCIAL AID
INVESTMENTS ADMIT THE CODED
NINETEEN CRISIS. CALIFORNIA'S
LANDMARK FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM WAS
LARGELY PRESERVED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
PROPOSES TO MAINTAIN THE CAL
GRANT SUPPLEMENT FOR STUDENTS
WITH DEPENDENTS THAT WAS
APPROVED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
ENSURING THAT STUDENT PARENTS
WITH FINANCIAL NEED CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE UP TO SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. FURTHERMORE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE DOES NOT
PROPOSE ANY CHANGES TO THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
MEANING THAT THE CONTEST
COMMISSION WILL CONTINUE TO
ISSUE FORTY ONE THOUSAND NEW
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARDS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ACADEMIC YEAR. THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVIVE ALSO PROPOSES TO
FULLY FUND THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM ENSURING
THAT MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS CAN
CONTINUE TO ACCESS FINANCIAL
AID RESOURCES DURING THE
ENSUING RECESSION. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE INCLUDE
THE REDUCTION TO THE MAXIMUM
CAL GRANT AWARD FOR NEW
RECIPIENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTION FROM NINE
THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS TO
EIGHT THOUSAND FIFTY SIX
DOLLARS CONSISTENT WITH ENACTED
STATUTE REGARDING TRANSFERRED
MISSION. THE COMMISSION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
MAINTAINING AND STRENGTHENING
CAL GRANT AID FOR ALL STUDENTS
WITH NEEDS. I HAVE THE
COMMISSION ALSO APPRECIATE SO
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR KEY NEW
PROGRAMS INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR
THE GRANT DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION. GDF THEM PROJECT.
THE DREAMER SERVICE INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM AND COMPLIACE
WITH THE NATIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION ACT. THE FUNDING
PROPOSAL FOR GSM ENSURES THAT
THE COMMISSION WILL COMPLETE
THE FINAL PHASE OF THE PROJECT
THUS FAR ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
HAS ALREADY BEEN INVESTED IN
THIS EFFORT. FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF GDS THEM
WHILE. GREATLY IMPROVE THE
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO SERVE
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. OF
STUDENTS APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL
AID I MAKE A EASIER FOR. TO
RELIABLY ACCESS WEB GRANTS FOR
STUDENTS FROM ANY DEVICE. I'M
MORE QUICKLY NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM. STREAMLINED COMPLEX
PROCESSES FOR WORKING WITH
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING YEAR AND
RECONCILIATION THAT'S ALLOWING
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES MORE TIME
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH STUDENTS.
AND ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO
ACCOMMODATE LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
IMPROVEMENTS AND NEW PROGRAMS
MORE EFFICIENTLY. JDS I'M
FUNDING WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO
PHASE OUT OUR OLD LEGACY SYSTEM
STATING SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
STAFF TIME AND RESOURCES.
WITHOUT THE PROPOSED FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION IN GDS THEM
FUNDING THE COMMISSION WOULD BE
FORCED TO MAINTAIN BOTH OUR
LEGACY RANT DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND THE NEW GSM SYSTEM WE ARE
BUILDING. THIS IS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN BUILT ON THE
NEW SYSTEM NAMELY OUR WEB GRANT
FOR STUDENTS INTERFACE AND
OTHER PARTS ARE STILL BEING
MAINTAINED BY THE LEGACY SYSTEM
FOR EXAMPLE INSTITUTIONS
INTERFACE THAT'S REQUIRING SIX
ACT TO MAINTAIN TWO SYSTEMS AND
CREATING DOUBLE THE WORK LOAD.
THE COMMISSION ALSO NOTES THE
REDUCTIONS IN FUNDING FOR THE
NEW GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM. AND WITH A NEW CHILD
SAVINGS ACCOUNT GRANT PROGRAM
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR MAY
REVISION. PENDING THE OUTCOME
OF THE FINAL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STATE BUDGET THE COMMISSION
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE NO NEW
PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE THE
REMAINING FUNDING IS
ADMINISTERED TO ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS. SO TO RICK WRAP UP MY
REMARKS STUDENTS WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO COVER THE COST OF
FOOD. HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
AND CHILDCARE PRIOR TO THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. AND
INEQUITIES IN COLLEGE ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY WILL ONLY BE
EXACERBATED BY COVERED NINETEEN.
IT IS MORE CRITICAL. THAN EVER
THAT CALIFORNIA PRIORITIZE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS. THE COMMISSION UP
WHAT'S THE STRONG COMMITMENT TO
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
DEMONSTRATED BY THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU.
STUDENTS ADVOCATES EMMA
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAXIMIZE MY ITS
FINANCIAL AID RESOURCES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS. THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY. OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS I KNOW- WE
USUALLY HEAR ONE- SEGMENT AT A
TIME AND GET TO CURE NAY BUT
WE'RE GONNA DO THESE ALL
TOGETHER THIS IS A CERTAINLY A
UNIQUE TIME WITH OUR PROPOSALS
HERE FOR THE MAY REVISE. I HAVE
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS BUT YOU
KNOW ALL START BY OPENING UP
TO. COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO. YOU
WERE THE FIRST ONE I SAW MAKE A
MOVE MISTER GALLAGHER SO. YOU
GO. WELL ALL STAR HERE AND HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS AND MAYBE ON
THIS BUT OTHERS ASSN WE COME
BACK. I THINK THE FIRST YEAR TO
CS YOU. I KNOW YOU GUYS CAME
OUT HERE LAST WEEK SAYING THAT
YOU WERE GOING TO YOU KNOW MAKE
A DECISION TO MOVE TO ONLINE
FOR NEXT FALL ACROSS THE BOARD-
YOU KNOW IT'S- OBVIOUSLY
SOMEWHAT OF A CONCERN AND THAT.
YOUR MANY OF THESE CAMPUSES
POTENTIALLY COULD BE RE OPENED
IN THE FALL WITH SAFETY
PROTOCOLS AND YOU KNOW AND WHAT
THESE CAMPUSES MEAN CERTAINLY'S
COMMUNITIES OTHERS GIVE EXAMPLE
OF CSU CHICO- THAT REPRESENT TO
YOU KNOW. OBVIOUSLY BIG FOR THE
COMMUNITY THE STUDENTS. BEING
THERE AND- EVERYTHING THAT THAT
THAT COMES WITH A COLLEGE TOWN-
BUT THIS IS REALLY SERVING THE
ENTIRE STATE YES CSU CHICO.
TWENTY POINT 5% COME FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA THE STUDENTS.
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. TWENTY
TWO POINT 1% COME FROM THE LOS
ANGELES AREA. AND SIXTEEN POINT
4% COME FROM OTHER RESCUE
CALIFORNIA AND- INTERESTING
FACT ONLY TWO POINT 5% OF THE
STUDENTS ARE OUT OF STATE. FOR
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS ARE CSU
CERTAINLY. SERVING CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. AND THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT YOU KNOW ONLINE. COURSES
ARE JUST NOT THE SAME AS WHAT
YOU GET IN CLASS WITH THE IN
PERSON. TIMES ON I MEAN LOOK I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT THERE'S A
LOT. OF CONCERN AND BUT THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF TIME BETWEEN NOW
AND THE FALL. I MEAN IS CSU
POSSIBLY CONSIDERING MAYBE
DOING THIS DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
THE ON A CAMPUS OR IS THAT IS
THE ALL ONLINE COURSES ACROSS
THE BOARD IS THAT KIND OF A
FINAL DECISION. AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
IT'S A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER THE FIRST ELEMENT
THAT WAS. DETERMINED WAS WHAT
IS THE BEST- BEST THING MOVING
FORWARD FOR OUR STUDENTS. LOTS
AND LOTS OF CONSULTATION
INTERNALLY WITHIN THE C. ISSUE-
AMONG THE PRESIDENTS OF EACH
THESE CAMPUSES AND THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP OF THE- OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. I THINK
ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT SOMETIMES HEADLINES IN
NEWSPAPERS ARE MISLEADING AND
SOMETIMES INFORMATION GETS
TWEAKED A LITTLE BIT
INCORRECTLY WHEN- I'M FAMILIAR
WITH THAT YEAH UP WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE PLANNING FOR A
VIRTUAL DELIVERY FOR THE FALL
AND FOR THE WINTER. AND THE
IDEA HERE IS THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO BE THE MOST EQUIPPED AND
BEST EQUIPPED TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER THE BEST INSTRUCTION WE
CAN'T POSSIBLY. ONE OF THOSE
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN BE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WITH OUR
STUDENTS IS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ADDITIONAL
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT MORE
THAN WE ALREADY HAVE. TO OFFER
FACULTY TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
EVEN A BETTER INSTRUCTIONAL OF
ANALOGY. IN THIS IN THIS TOUGH
SITUATION. SO I THINK WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT ALLOWS FOR US TO BE
NIMBLE GOING FORWARD THE
CHALLENGES THAT CHANCE ARE
MENTIONED AT A RECENT BOARD
MEETING IS IF WE DECIDED TO GO
IN PERSON. YEAH I KNOW THAT'S
IDEAL THE WHAT EVERYBODY WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT'S
OUR GREATEST A WHILE THE STREAM
TO BE BACK- NOT TALKING TO
PEOPLE WITH MASKS AND THAT SORT
OF THING. IF WE GO IN PERSON
AND THEN ABRUPTLY HAVE TO DO
WHAT WE DID IN MARCH IT IS
INCREDIBLY DISRUPTIVE TO ALL
ELEMENTS OF. COMMUNITIES AND
ESPECIALLY THE STUDENTS. AND
FACULTY IN OUR STATE THAT HAVE
TO DO WOULD HAVE TO REPEAT THIS
AGAIN. BUT THERE A COUPLE BUT
INSTEAD TO THINK THROUGH TO
HERE THIS IS NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH SO THE
ARTICLE HEADLINES THAT WAS
TELLING YOU ABOUT- ARE SAYING
THAT YOU KNOW SEE ISSUE GOING
ALL ONLINE. AND THAT MIGHT BE
THE PERIOD BEHIND IT. OVER
PLANNING FOR PLANNING THAT
DIRECTION BUT THEY'RE GONNA BE
INSTANCES WHERE THAT'S NOT
PRACTICAL NURSING STUDENTS WHO
HAVE THAT PRACTICAL RIGHT.
THERE ARE GONNA BE AGRICULTURAL
STUDENTS WHO HAVE TO BE IN THE
FIELDS AND LEARNING HOW THAT
TRACTOROPERATES AND HOW TO. DO
SOIL SAMPLE. SORTS OF OUR TO BE
A OF HIS BY K. REVIEW. THE
CHAIR OFFICE. PROVIDED
EXEMPTION. SO THAT IN THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE. ENGINEERING
STUDENTS NEED TO DO THEIR
CAPSTONE AND IT IS A PHYSICAL
EXPERIENCE. THAT THERE WILL BE
AN APPROPRIATE WAIVER WHERE
JUSTIFIED. AND SECONDLY. THAT
THERE IS A APPROPRIATE PP AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING. THE OTHER
FACTOR TO OF COURSE BUT TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES SPREAD ACROSS TO
EIGHT HUNDRED NINE HUNDRED
MILES OF THIS. GREAT STATE OF
OURS- UP WHERE YOU HAVE I ONLY
DID IT AS SITUATIONS LOCALLY.
WHAT'S GOING ON L. LATE IN IN
THE LA BASIN IT. THE MID
NINETEEN IT'S GOING TO BE
GROSSLY DIFFERENT THAN THAN
YOUR BELOVED CHICO STATE. SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE NOT
SEEING A PLAN TO PLAN FOR. IN
THOSE INSTANCES WHERE WE CAN GO
PHYSICAL WE CAN AND WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE BUT- BUT I THINK
GENERALLY SPEAKING OUR GOAL IS
TO ALWAYS KEEP THE STUDENTS IN
IN MIND FIRST. WE WOULD ALL
LOVE TO DO FACE TO FACE WE
WOULD ALL LOVE TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN. BUT BECAUSE
OF THE CURRENT SITUATION WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL. SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE AND IN. APPROPRIATE
SO THAT STUDENTS ARE ACHIEVING
THE BEST LEARNING OUTCOMES
POSSIBLE AND NOT HAVING AGAIN
TO REPEAT. POTENTIALLY OF WHERE
IT'S INCREDIBLY DISRUPTIVE AT
SOME VARIOUS IN CRITICAL POINTS
I MEAN. ONE OF THE WHEN THE
FORECAST FOR LATE FALL THAT
COULD BE A PERFECT STORM RIGHT
BEFORE- A FINALS WHERE DUDLEY
YOUR YOUR WORK ALL SEMESTER OR
ALL QUARTER. TO A GRINDING HALT
SO WE WANT TO BE AS AS PREPARED
AS POSSIBLE. GIVE US MUCH OP.
STILL TO BE ABLE TO DO NOT ONLY
GET THEIR DEGREES TO ACT. I
WOULD THINK THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER AND THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR
KIND OF MORE THE DETAILS OF HOW
THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE.
WORKING OUT. THE KIND OF
SIMILAR TO YESTERDAY'S HEARING
I WANT TO DELVE INTO THIS ISSUE
OF YOU KNOW. IN THE REVISE THE
GOVERNOR IS SAYING. LOOK WE ARE
GOING TO- HAVE SOME PRETTY
DRASTIC CUTS REALLY BASICALLY A
10% CUT ACROSS THE BOARD AT ALL
OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION. AN
INSANE BUT WILL TRIGGER THOSE
OFF. IF WE GET SUFFICIENT
FEDERAL FUNDS WELL THE REALITY
IS WE DID GET FEDERAL FUNDS-
FOR OUR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
FACT- THE CARES ACT THE FIRST
ONE- CAME THROUGH WITH ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IS
ULTIMATELY WHAT I COME THROUGH
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
MILLION FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HAVE INTERNED FIVE
MILLION FOR SEAT YOU AND TURN
SIXTY MILLION FOR YOU SEE. HALF
OF THOSE FUNDS BEING CREATED
FOR FINANCIAL AID. SO GET MY
QUESTION BECOMES WHY DON'T WE
TRIGGER THAT OFF RIGHT NOW-
SOON BE AS THOUGH WE DID GET
FEDERAL FUNDS THE FED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. HAS IN FACT
COME THROUGH. WITH SUPPORTS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND SO
CONSIDERING THAT FACT MAYBE WE
SHOULD START TRIGGERING OFF
THESE CUTS. RIGHT NOW OMIT
DOESN'T PULL OUT A SENSE TO BE
PULLING BACK STATE AID- IN
SUPPORT AND INCLUDING.
FINANCIAL AID I MEAN WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT AS
WELL- BUT I QUESTION TO DO
LAUGH- WHOEVER WANTS TO ANSWER
THIS WOULD BE. YOU KNOW WHY IT
WHY NOT TRIGGER OFF SOME OF
THOSE CUTS. RIGHT NOW
CONSIDERING THAT WE HAVE SEAT
RECEIVED SUBSTANTIAL. FEDERAL
SUPPORT FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
THE STATE. YEAH IN A FINANCE I
THINK- WHAT WE WOULD SAY TO
THAT IS THAT THESE RESOURCES
CAN ASSIST OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
IN- MITIGATING THE IMPACTS OF
THE PROPOSED REDUCTIONS BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THEY ARE A
DIGITAL COSTS AS WELL AS
HELPING STE A I. A MAIN DISH
EARNING. THOSE RESOURCES ARE TO
THE IN COVERING THE COSTS-
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROPOSED-
REDUCTIONS RIGHT BUT THEY
STEPPED UP SO WHERE WE BACKING
OFF. I THINK FROM FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. WE HAVE ALSO WE
ARE AWARE THAT THE UNIVERSITIES
HAVE ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH A CODE NINETEEN
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
MITIGATING THE IMPACTS TO OUR
MOST UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT
POPULATIONS. WHY I STILL DON'T
HEAR MUCH OF AN ANSWER THERE
BUT LOOK AT I MEAN FOR ME AND
FROM MY STANDPOINT HE WAS THE
THIS ROOM RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT ARE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS ARE- ANY OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALTHOUGH KENYA. TO THE
CS USED TO THE UC'S. NO AS I
JUST TALKED ABOUT CHICO STATE
SERVING STUDENTS THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE AND THAT IS AND THAT
IS THE CASE IN ALL OF OUR
UNIVERSITIES A BY CRITICAL.
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET TO A PLACE. WHAT
WE HELP ENSURE THAT. ADEQUATE
FUNDING. FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
LOOK WE ALL RECOGNIZE. OF
COURSE THAT WE'RE IN A VERY
DIRE SITUATION YOU KNOW HUGE
REVENUE SHORTFALL. AS A RESULT
OF COVERT NINETEEN BUT IT'S IN
THE TOUGH BUDGET TIMES THAT
EVEN MORE SO BUDGET SEEM TO BE
ABOUT PRIORITIES. AND CERTAINLY
ARE HIGHER EDUCATION EVERYTHING
THAT THEY PROVIDE- SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY IN THIS AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE ARE IN FACT TO GET
FEDERAL SUPPORT. OUR EDUCATION-
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. YELP
YEAH I THINK IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE- MAKE THE
COMMITMENT STATE LEVEL TO KEEP
TRYING KEEP THAT STABLE AS WELL
SO. I THINK WE SHOULD BE REALLY
LOOKING AT THAT SIR JUST DOING
A 10% ACROSS THE BOARD CUT
LET'S TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE-
THE FEDERAL SUPPORT THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED. AND
REALLY LOOK CAN WE KIND OF KEEP
THESE THINGS AS AS STABLE AS
POSSIBLE- MAYBE JUST TWO MORE
QUICK QUESTIONS ONE. IN THE
FINANCIAL AID PORTION. IT LOOKS
LIKE WE'RE CUTTING I THINK IT'S
11% IN CAL GRANTS TO PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES. AND SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS WHY THE INEQUITY
THERE WERE FOCUSING REALLY AND
SEEMS LIKE REALLY TARGETED
FINANCIAL AID CUTS TO THE
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES. YOU KNOW
OUR STUDENTS ARE GETTING
EDUCATION THERE AS WELL THERE
EVERY EVERY BIT AS DESERVING OF
HELP AND SUPPORT AND THEIR
EDUCATION WHY ARE WE PICKING ON
THE. HI I LIKE TRAVIS WITH THE
PAYMENT. FINANCE THEY'RE JUST
MINUTES SIMPLY AND I JUST WANT
TO ADDRESS CURRENT LAW. I'M
BETTING QUITE HERE YET COULD
YOU SAY THAT AGAIN I'M SORRY.
YES HI. THE I. CHOPS MONIES TO
CONFER WITH CURRENT LAW.
CURRENT ASSETS THE AMOUNT OF
THE AWARD FOR THE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS. THEY
HAD A TARGET FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND THE CITIZENS DID
NOT MEET THE TARGET. OKAY SO
THEY'D YOU STANNIS BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT MEET AT TARGET FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS. AND THAT'S
WHY THE REDUCTION IS MORE THEIR.
CORRECT THERE IS THAT IT'S
TOUGH TO THREE- REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE CITY IT'S JUST- TO LET
ME TRANSFER STUDENTS. OKAY WELL
I. I'M NOT SURE ABOUT- YOU KNOW
THAT SPECIFIC JUSTIFICATION I
DO KNOW THAT WE STILL HAVE
STUDENTS THAT YOU KNOW EVERY
PLACE OF HIGHER LEARNING THAT
ARE STILL TRYING TO MAINTAIN
THAT EDUCATION THAT NEEDS TO.
WHAT. DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BE FAVORING ONE FORM OF.
EDUCATION OVER THE OTHERS THESE
PEOPLE STILL NEED SUPPORT TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR EDUCATION SO-
I GUESS I'D PROBABLY WANT TO
GET SOME MORE INFORMATION ON.
YOU KNOW WHAT. JUST FOR ASIAN
THERE IS THERE BUT IT IT SEEMS
TO ME TO BE DISCRIMINATORY AND
THEN I GUESS TO SEE AS YOU DID
YOU HAVE A GO AHEAD. SO I SAID
I'D BRIANNA FRIENDS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO AS MY COLLEAGUE
EVERY ELEMENT EXPLAINING THIS
IS A TECHNICAL- ENACTMENT OF
CURRENT LAW. AS THE IT
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTIONS TO.
MEET THEIR AT T. TARGETS THE
CAL GRANT AMOUNT. IS REDUCED.
HOWEVER SHOULD THEY BE ABLE TO
MEET THOSE TARGETS AS THEY ERE
AND- INSTATED IN CURRENT
STATUTE THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT ACTUALLY AUTOMATICALLY GO
BACK UP TO THE ORIGINAL ABOUT.
SO SHOULD THAT TARGET IN THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR OUR NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. IF THEY WERE TO
MEET IT AT ANY POINT SO IF THEY
WERE TO BEAT IT AND THE SPRING
THAN THAT NOT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY GO UP TO THE
ORIGINAL AMOUNT I'M SURE THEY
NEED YOU TO HEAR THAT IN THE
FUTURE YEAR THAT A CALDERON
OUTLOOK BUT- I'D ALSO ASK. HE
WAY BILL CURRENT LAW. UNDER
BRINGS IN THE BIG OVER HARD
RISK A HIGH AMOUNT OF GRANT IN.
OKAY GOOD IN ON ME BECAUSE I
WOULD WANT TO PUNISH STUDENTS.
I HAVE FOR SOMETHING BUT I BUT
I WOULD ADD YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
THIS REAL DEMAND ON YOU SEAT TO
INCREASE THEIR IN STATE
ENROLLMENT. AND MANY OF THOSE
CAMPUSES HAVE NOT MET THAT
REQUIREMENT- INCLUDING
BERKELEY- INCLUDING UCLA. ARE
WE ARE WE PULLING. ARE CUTTING
CAL GRANT FUNDING. TO PEOPLE
THERE THAT THEY'RE NOT MEETING
REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT WE WOULD
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE IS WANTED
THEM- TO MEET. AS WE ARE THEY
GETTING THE SAME TREATMENT. I
KNOW IT I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
SPIRITS OF CALIFORNIA HAVE TO
ADD TO FOR TO MY COLLEAGUES
HOWEVER THIS SPECIFIC STATUTE
WAS FOR THE INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT- COLLEGES- AND
THERE'S A SPECIFIC STATUTE I
CAN GET THAT YOUR STOCK ON IT
OUTLINES THEIR- BACK. BUT IT
SPECIFICALLY FOR TWO FORTY
INDEPENDENT PLEDGES I. ARE AND
AT T. TRANSFER LEVEL. WELL YEAH
I MEAN YOU GO HEAD INTERJECT
RIGHT HERE I THOUGHT I'D I
THINK TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO.
WE MADE THE DECISION TO RE ST
THE CUTS TO THE PRIVATE
SITUATIONS FOR CAL BECAUSE
THOSE ARE IN THERE THE
RECESSION. EVERY WOULD THEY
FOUGHT TO RESTORE THOSE WE DID
LIKE A ONE YEAR YOU KNOW FIX
EVERY YEAR THAN FINALLY WAS YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS IS GET RID OF
THIS WE SAID YOU KNOW AS PART
OF THE GRAND AS IT'S HAVE YOU
DO SOME. BASS HELP US. THANK
YOU AND AS- WE COULD- THE
GOVERNOR'S HERE WHAT WILL STIR
WILL STILL EVALUATING THAT BUT
THERE WAS A AND AN ARRANGEMENT-
FOR THEM TO ACCEPT MORE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CALLED
TRANSFER STUDENTS AND BUT
THAT'S IS ABOUT BUT- ANYWAY- SO
AND THEN ALL RIGHT ISSUE MORE
UNLESS THING OF AND I APOLOGIZE.
CAMPUS IS. PS USE I KNOW THERE
WAS AN AUDIT. THE TARGET OF
THESE CAMPUS FEES. YOU KNOW.
WHAT WHAT ARE WE GOING TO BE
SEEN IN TERMS OF ON THE CSU
CAMPUS AND IN REGARD TO EASE NO
ACTUALLY IN LIGHT OF THIS THIS
AUDIT THAT RECENTLY CAME OUT.
AND IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IN THIS REVISED. WHAT IS
A FIRST. HE'S FEES PAY FOR
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE A TUITION
TUITION IS A FEAT. AS YOU WELL
KNOW GREAT RECESSION WE LOST
ONE THIRD OF OUR TUITION WE
LOST ONE THIRD OF OUR GENERAL
FUND SPORT AND DURING THAT AS A
REAR. AS A NECESSARY REACTION
TO MAKE SURE OUR STUDENTS WERE
OF THE EDUCATED IN AND RIGHT AT
THE PRO LEVEL SERVICE. THESE
WERE BASED AS WELL AS TUITION
WAS. BUT IT'S PREMATURE AT THIS
POINT SAYS SAY WHETHER WE WILL
TUITION AT THIS POINT- TERMS OF
FEES ARE SEPARATE- ELABORATE
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE ABOLITION.
THE REQUIRES. CONSULTATION AND
BOATS OF STUDENTS ON ON THE
LOCAL CAMPUSES THAT THEN
REQUIRES THAT PRESIDENT TO
EITHER APPROVE- AN INCREASE OR
DECREASE. PROBLEM SHOULD HAVE
FEE SO THAT POLICY THE PLAY.
RIGHT NOW- WHAT LESS THAN ARE
WE ABOUT A WEEK- OF A WAVE OF
THAT VISION PROPOSALS. I THINK.
THAT AN OUNCE IT'S HARD TO
BREATH SPEC. WHETHER WE WOULD
BE USING ANY. AT THIS TIME NOR
NOR TUITION. IS A SET
STATEMENT. DURING TIMES LIKE
THIS IN THIS. OPTIMAL TIME TO
USE THE WILL KICK YOU SET. I
DIDN'T LIKE WAYS IN WHICH TO
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THE
REVENUE BASE AT THIS POINT IT'S
JUST FAR TOO EARLY TO SAY
WHETHER THAT'S EVEN. POSSIBLE
ON. THAT WE ARE A- THIS. OKAY
I'LL DEFER TO MY OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH. WHAT.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
NOTICED GALLAGHER STERN GREAT
BOB THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR-
AND JUST JUST QUICKLY HERE I
JUST WANT OF APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S HEART BROKEN UP THIS
IS NOT A PLEASANT EXERCISE TO
GO THROUGH. IT AT YOU. AND DO
IT DO YOU I JUST SEE QUICKLY IN
THE CSU AND I BRING THAT THE
PERSPECTIVE I BRINGS OUT OF THE
CHAIR OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND A TEACHER. AND
SOMEONE. IS KIND OF THE NUMBERS
OF THE SEAT. ISSUE IN UC SYSTEM
REALLY THE CSU SYSTEM IS. THE
CHANCE SO LIKES TO CALL UP A
SHOW HORSE. I LIKE TO CALL IT.
THE WAR COURSE OF CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM AYE AYE
A STONE SOME LEVEL IT'S BOTH-
BUT I DO. IT I MEANT. I'M
PLEASED WITH YOUR STORE ABOUT.
REAL ONE WHICH ABOUT THE CO
NINETEEN CRISIS YEAR. DIVERSE
OF CALIFORNIA WELL MAY COME
INTO PLAY IN THE FALL OF NOT
THE WINTER. EFFECTIVE SEEN SOME
SCHOOLS CROSSES. YOU STATES.
RIGHT ASIAN. ARE SO UP THEIR
SCHOOL YOU'RE GONNA START
EARLIER IN AUGUST- AND THEY'RE
GONNA GET OUT ABOUT
THANKSGIVING BECAUSE THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT A SURGE COMING IN
THE WINTER MONTHS. I THOUGHT
THAT WAS THAT'S JUST SOMETHING
HOPE PEOPLE CAUGHT I'M NOT
GONNA TELL YOU WHEN TO GO IN
WHEN THEY GO OUT THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING TO CONTEMPLATE BUT I
DO APPRECIATE THE- ADVANTAGE
TRAFFIC VIRTUALLY. HUMBOLDT IS
A PLATE. STATE HOUSE LA. SO
THANK YOU MATT AND JUST JUST
THING THAT CAN PICK MY INTEREST
HERE. WELL TO MAKE A COMMON IN
THIS MONEY THE GOVERNOR PUT. E.
C. SO THAT THE SUBJECT. MATTER
FACT THAT. MUCH RESULTING FROM
COVER NINETEEN ON MY- YOU SEE
WHAT'S THAT AND- I JUST THINK
IT RELIGION THAT THOSE KINDS OF
TASH REFORM THE CSU LEVEL GIVEN
THAT THEY THE ONES THAT PRODUCE
TO OUR- OUR OUR TEACHER. SAID
WE WANT PARTY'S. I AND A LOT
FROM MY A PERSPECTIVE THAT
INFORMATION DOES GET HER. TO
THE CSU EVEN OUT OF THE UC
SYSTEM SOME OF THE STUDIES THAT
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED IN THE PAST
I THINK THEY KIND OF KIND OF
STATE YOU SEE THE WORLD DON'T
LEAVE THE WORLD. YET THIS
TI<c.cyan> WORLD IS THE ONE THAT'S</c>
REALLY. THERE ARE FEW. YEARS SO
I HOPE THERE WOULD BE SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. AND
WITH THAT I TURNED IT BACK TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR. YES THANK
YOU- I HEAR YOU ON THAT
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS I WILL JUST NOTE THAT
DOWN. THAT'S A NEW INITIATIVE
IF. NO NO YOU SEE AS- THE ACT
AS YOU WAS. THE FIRST. FOR
TRAINING THE SEA IS SYSTEM BUT
THE THIS PROP BACK TO A- EXPERT
BEING. YOU KNOW A- AS FOR IN
DIFFERENT SUBJECT MATTERS BIRD
I THINK TWENTY YEARS IT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IN THE UC SYSTEM SO I
THINK THIS IS JUST AN EXPANSION
OF THAT WELL IF I COULD TURN A
WE ARE TAKE A LOOK SWITCHING
OVER TO THIS NEW SYSTEM DOES
AGAIN I MEANT. THERE THE CENTER
THING ARE FUTURE CHEERS BYE
LARGE THE- SEE SYSTEM BUT IT.
DOESN'T TO HAVE. IF SHE DOESN'T
THE NUMBERS THAT THIS YEAR'S
USE HAS OR ORDERED TO BE THE
PRIORITY- THAT THE CSU MAKES IT
SO I HOPE WE WOULD HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. OKAY THANK YOU
YOU KNOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FIRST TO- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEN I'LL GO TO YOU
TO SEE AN END TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT I WANTED
TO FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CHICO. WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON CAL GRANTS. SO WE
GET HAVE SOMEBODY. THERE FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
REMINISCENT OF A NATIONAL
CONVENTION. THANK YOU HAVE IS
THANK YOU. BRINGING UP THE SAME
POINT AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM-
CHICO ON THE READ 11%
REDUCTION- TO THE- PRIVATE
COLLEGES AND TO STUDENTS
ATTENDING THE PRIVATE COLLEGES
AS CHAIR OF HIGHER ED AYE AYE
WE DOUBT. IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE
IT IN OUR ATTEMPT TO GO IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION IT HAD BEEN
ATTACHED TO NOT. IN A SET TO
PUNISH THE PRIVATES FROM WHEN
TO COME BACK EVERY YEAR TO MAKE
THE CASE OF WHY THEIR STUDENTS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO
POINTED OUT DESERVED TO HAVE
THE SAME AMOUNT OF- FINANCIAL
AID AS THOSE ATTACKS. STATE AND
THE UC. AND I THINK THAT WAS
THE WAY WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
MOVE. SO THE QUESTION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YOU SAY
THAT THE PRIVATES DID NOT MEET.
I'M HEARING THAT THE TRANSFER
GOALS THAT WERE SET OUT IS THAT
OVERALL DO DO SUCH. NEEDED AND
OTHERS DID NOT BUT BUT ALL OF
THEM- ARE FACING THE ALL THE
STUDENTS ARE FACING THE SAME
CUTS IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN. THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETY
BUDGET ACT- YOU INCLUDED THIS
TARGETS. BUT INSTITUTIONS MADE
ONE THOUSAND AND TEN
TRANSFERRED OUT THE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THEM TO DO TWO
THOUSAND. SHOW THAT OVERALL ALL
ALL YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING ALL OF
PRIVATES TOGETHER. THIS IS IN
RESPONSE TO THE- ASSOCIATE UP
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES REPORT THIS IS
WHAT THEY PROVIDE. RIGHT BUT I
WOULD ASSUME THAT SOME COLLEGES
MET THEIR GOALS AND OTHERS DID
NOT. AND WE ARE YOU KNOW
BLANKETING AND TREAT THEM ALL
THE SAME. SHOP AT THREE I RENTS
REVEREND FINANCE I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT IT'S NOT UNIVERSITY
SPECIFIC IT'S FOR THE WHOLE OF
THE A ALL AICC YOU INSTITUTIONS.
YEAH NOW THE AYE AYE I WOULD
CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CHICO THAT IT SEEMS.
DISCRIMINATORY THAT WE ARE YOU
KNOW USING. WITH THE SAME
BRUSH. MADE IT YOU MET YOUR-
DID NOT. AND I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT THAT I OF PERSON
DISAGREE WITH THIS PROPOSAL OF
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WOULD WANT TO SEE. INDEPENDENT
STUDENTS RECEIVING THE SAME.
FINANCIAL AID. AS AS THEIR- AS
THEIR- WHETHER WHETHER THEY
ATTEND A PRIVATE OR A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY- IT CERTAINLY SEEMS.
EQUITABLE SO I JUST WENT TO A
WEIGH IN ON THAT ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES OF FROM G. CALL. TO
YOU SEE. ALL OF A. I WANNA I
WANNA THANK YOU SEE- FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION AND I BELIEVE THE
FIRST TWO SPEAKERS THAT CAME
BEFORE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH- APPLAUDED THE
GOOD FOR KEEPING THE ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. YOU SEE ARE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE- IN THE
BUDGET. AND IT CERTAINLY
SOMETHING TO BE PROUD OF I JUST
WANT TO REMIND THIS COMMITTEE
THAT IT WAS IT. ALMOST EIGHT
IT'S AGO WHEN- SENATOR ROTH AND
MYSELF ON OUR FIRST DAY HERE-
AS SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION. TO FUND THE UC OUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND WE DID
IT WITH FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING APPROPRIATE ACTION.
THAT WAS FIFTIES ONCE THE BEGAN
AT THE ARE AND WITH GREAT.
POSTED THAT NOW EVERY EVERY
YEAR IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
SO THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS FIRST PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INTENDED TO DOUBLE THE SIZE OF
THE UC OUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
YOU SEE ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
WAS THE FIRST PUBLIC SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WEST OF THE
MISSISSIPPI SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE. AND I JUST
REMINDING OF. THIS BODY THAT OF
THE NUMBER OF DOCTORS- IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE LIKE. INLAND
CALIFORNIA IS MUCH LESS THAN ON
THE COAST MUCH MUCH LESS AND AT
THIS CRISIS JUST HIGHLIGHTS
THAT NEED FOR DOCTORS AND
INLAND CALIFORNIA SO- AS A
MEMBER OF THE INLAND CAUCUS WE
PRESENTED- MR TANG AND SENATOR
MITCHELL. WITH THE LETTER
FOURTEEN DIFFERENT OF MEMBERS
OF BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY SIGNED ON BIPARTISAN A
INCLUDING MY COLLEAGUE.
OBERNOLTE FROM BIG BEAR-
BIPARTISAN AND FOR BOTH
SENATORS AND- ANDASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND I WOULD JUST CONCUR
WITH UC. THAT WE LOOK AT A UP
APPROPRIATING THE WHOLE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS YOU SEE
ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IS A
BARGAIN. NO OTHER MEDICAL
SCHOOL- IN UC IS DOING AS MUCH
WITH AS LITTLE. IT IS A UNIQUE
PROGRAM THERE IS NO HOSPITAL IT
IS A PROGRAM THAT IS. CREATED
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE TO MEET THE CULTURAL
NEEDS OF DIVERSE POPULATION AND
I AM SURE THAT IF IT HAD NOT
BEEN FOR THE CORONA VIRUS- RICE
IS THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW WE
WOULD HAVE- SOMEONE- MEDICAL
STUDENT FROM YOU SEE ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY. SO I WOULD JUST
HOPE THAT- WE WILL CONSIDER THE
WHOLE TWENTY FIVE MILLION-
APPROPRIATION TO THE UC OUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IT IS MUCH
NEEDED AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SIGNED ON THAT
LETTER. DO YOU SEE. NO NO. WITH
THANK YOU THAT TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SYSTEM. THE. THANK YOU. AS AS-
AS MY COLLEAGUES KNOW I COME
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM RICE SERVED THIRTEEN
YEARS AS A- TRUSTEE AND
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I
WAS A PART TIME INSTRUCTOR IN
THE SALMON A DINO AND COLLEGE
OF THE DESERT. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS BUT I AM
CONCERNED AS MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE WITH THAT
DUPLICATION. AND RUN AWAY
EXPENSES WITH THE CAL BRIGHT
COLLEGE. AND I THINK THAT
DURING THESE DIFFICULT TIMES WE
SHOULD VERY MUCH CONSIDER.
ELIMINATING COMPLETELY THE
FUNDING TO CALL RIGHT COLLEGE
ALTOGETHER AND RE DIRECT THOSE
FUNDS TO EXISTING PROGRAMS AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND I SAY THAT. NOT
EASILY. IN I HAD CALLED FOR AN
AUDIT OF THE CALIBRATE COLLEGE
AND WE PUT THAT AUDIT OFF. TO A
LATER DATE THE OUT IT HAD BEEN
ASTON APPROVED THE WE PUSH IT
OUT TO A LATER DATE SO WE COULD
SEE WHAT BUDGET SITUATION WE
ARE IN. BUT NOW A FEW MONTHS
LATER WE SEE THE DIRE. BUDGET
SITUATION THAT WE ARE IN AND I
DON'T BELIEVE PERSONALLY THAT
WE CAN AFFORD- SUCH A SYSTEM-
THAT IS GOING THROUGH SO MANY
DIFFICULTIES AND-
ADMINISTRATIVELY- AND NOT
REALLY SERVING THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
ACTUALLY HAVE A QUESTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
ASKED FOR A CUT OF MY CORRECT
OF THE CAL RIGHT COLLEGE
DISTRICT. CORRECT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION TO
HELP MAKE COLLEGE AND CAN YOU.
TELL ME WHY THERE WERE NOT
FURTHER CUTS- TO THAT COLLEGE
DISTRICT- ASKED FOR. WHITE WHY
ONLY THREE MILLION. WHETHER THE
REDUCTION TO CALIBRATE COLLEGES
LARGELY IN LINE FOR WITH OTHER
REDUCTIONS THAT WE WERE MAKING
ACROSS THE STATE AS WE NOTED-
AS WAS NOTED AT THE TOP THERE
IS A 10% REDUCTION AND TO THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA
ALONG WITH. OF MULTIPLE OF
REJECTION SICK CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS 15% REDUCTIONS IN MANY
CASES AND- BUT IN THIS CASE THE
THREE THREE MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION IS A PERCENT
REDUCTION TO THEIR ONGOING.
CREATION THANKYOU AND THOSE
ARE ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW OBERNOLTE. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY POIGNANT EXPERIENCE
TO BE SITTING UP HERE ON THIS
DíAS AND CONTEMPLATING.
TERRIBLE AT WE ARE
CONTEMPLATING TO MAKE IT IN-
THE THING FOR HIRED XIN IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT TO A MAN ALL OF
THIS RENTS HAVE TESTIFIED THAT-
THEY REQUEST THAT WE NOT CUT
THEIR FUNDING AND- I BELIEVE ME
MESSAGE RECEIVED WE WOULD WE DO
NOT WANT TO CUT FUNDING BUT
WERE PRESSED THE BUDGET CRISIS.
AND GATHERED BUT YOU AND- YOU
KNOW SOMETHING IS GOT TO BE
DONE HERE AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE IN THIS ROOM. I HAD A
QUESTION FOR ALL OF THE
SEGMENTS AND I'D LIKE TO START
WITH. THE CSU- AND THEN MAYBE
GO TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THEN THE UC BUT IT RELATES
TO A QUESTION THAT MISTER
GALLAGHER HAD ASKED HER. ABOUT
KEEP THIS FOR AN OUR THAT WHAT
SHE WAS UP THE- AN A GROUP AND
TO. DISCUSS TUITION MY QUESTION
IS THIS. I WOULD WILL BE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHAT THE
PLAN IS IF WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THESE CUTS- IF. WE HAVE. TO
COVER THEM IF WE ARE GOING TO
INCREASE JENNIFER COULD HAVE TO
DECREASE ROMAN. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO CHANGE THE MIXTURE OF
STUDENTS TO. MORE OF STATE
ROOMS ARE NO I THINK THAT'S A
QUESTION AND I OF THE UC SAID
THAT IT'S PREMATURE TO ASK THAT
QUESTION. I DISAGREE BECAUSE
WE'RE HAVE TO BE MAKING
DECISIONS. BASED ON THIS
INFORMATION THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS TO PASS A BUDGET BFORE
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE OF
JUNE FIFTEENTH SO WE NEED THAT
INFORMATION NOW SUCH MY CAN IS.
IF WE ARE FOR TECH. BUT TO ME
WORK OUT HERE. WHAT WOULD BE
THE RESPONSE. WELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OVER ALL THE- THAT WAS
ME ALL RIGHT SIR PERCY ISSUE
THAT MADE THAT THE COMMENTS
ABOUT TUITION FEES NOT YOU SEE
SO I DON'T WANNA. LET LET LET
HER BE OF BLAME FOR BRING IT
THE T. WORD. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE THINK OVER THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO- WE ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE IS- ABLE
TO. PIECE TOGETHER- SOME SORT
OF- STATUS QUO SORT OF
SITUATION WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT I MENTIONED IN MY
INITIAL OPENING COMMENTS AT.
ALL I ONE OF THE THINGS OF
COURSE IS WE ARE RECEIVING ONE
TIME READ PERSPECTIVE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO FOR
COVERT RELATE CAUGHT. AND KNEW
WHAT. THIS HELPFUL. LIGHTS BUT
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
OF OUR ONE TIME A DESIGNATED
BALANCES AND RESERVES. I WOULD
BE ABLE TO UTILIZE THAT WOULD
TALK THAT IN A- IN A STRATEGIC
AND- AND- AND- THE WAY IN ORDER
SO THAT WE COULD. DO A CRISIS
LIKE THIS. THINGS WERE MADE OF
THAT WILL. YIELD I THINK
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS OVER TIME.
OUR UP THREE THIS. NOBODY FOR
THIS TO OCCUR BUT OBVIOUSLY IN
THE SHORT TERM- MOST
DEPARTMENTS I GENERALLY SEE A
TURNOVER OF ABOUT 5% I DON'T
THINK WE'RE MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
IN THE YEAR. THAT WILL YIELD
TEMPORARY IS WELL AS WELL AS IF
WE WERE TO HOLD THOSE POSITIONS
OPEN- IT. OR LIMIT SEC
POSITIONS SO WE HAVE A NUMBER.
IS AVAILABLE ON. THE FORGET WE
ALSO HAVE THIS THING NO. NOT
TRAVEL. WE'VE I THINK ALL OF US
ALL OF TESTIFIED TO THE TWO
DOCKING THAT OUT AND SIMPLY
BECAUSE- BASICALLY CAN'T
TROUBLES IS ANYWAY. SO THAT IN
THE IN THE SHORT TERM WE CAN WE
CAN PIECE IT TOGETHER. ITHINK
THE ONE THING THAT WILL OCCUR
AND IT'S GREAT THAT YOU'RE
ASKING THIS QUESTION. IS THAT
IF THIS IS A REPEAT IF IT ENDS
UP BEING A REPEAT LIKE THE
GREAT RISK BACK. FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT ON THROUGH A
TWENTY ELEVEN TWENTY TWELVE. AT
AS THESE ONE TIME SOLUTIONS DRY
UP. AS WE DEPLETE. AT YOU CAN'T.
WE CAN'T BOIL. TIME WE WILL I
TURNED IT MORE PAY IS TO PLOY
THOSE BE IN DROPS THOSE COULD
BE TUITION. THOSE COULD BE A
HOST OF THINGS THAT CAN BE MORE
ON GOING AND MORE PAINFUL TO
THE STUDENT EXPERIENCE BOTH IN
THE INSTRUCTOR WORLD AS IN THE
SUPPORT WORLD WE HOPE WE DON'T
THERE ARE AT THIS POINT. WE
BOARD. DAY MANY OF THEM STATED
BOTH AT NO. FROM THEIR VANTAGE
THEIR PERSONAL VANTAGE POINT OR
DESIRE FOR THERE TO BE A TO
INCREASE NOT TIME WILL TELL AS
WE GO FOR RIGHT IF THIS IS
WORST AND THE GROUP SESSION. AN
OBVIOUS ALL THE OPTION AFTER.
ABLE THAT'S THAT'S THE REALITY
GOING FORWARD I THINK WE ARE IN
A PRETTY GOOD SHAPE TO START
HERE- WE HAVE LIKE LIKE THE
STATE HAS A RAINY DAY FUND THAT
HAS PAID OFF A COUPLE OF THOSE
DEBT. FOR RECEPTIONS. IT
ADDITION. TO SEE ISSUE. BUT
MARCHES ON AND THEN. AS THE
ADMINISTRATION SIX THAT THIS IS
A FOUR YEARS WORTH OF PAIN AND
RECURRING SITUATED WHERE
PERHAPS THE UNIVERSITY SAYS.
OUR SO TO SPEAK WE THE-
QUESTION THEN THE BE CHALLENGES
WHERE- FEES WILL BE ON THE
TABLE TO WHICH WILL BE ON THE
TABLE OTHER MEN OF WHERE YOU
ARE NOT ALL THAT SUCH A SET.
REALITY WHAT WERE. WE CAN
AVOID. BOTH WORK FOR IT MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE ROLL FORWARD
THAT WE ARE PUTTING IN PLACE
THINGS THAT ARE. JEFF ENOUGH SO
THAT WE DON'T. STUDENTS TUITION
INCREASES JUST SO THAT WE ARE
NOT HAVING TO EMPLOY. SO THAT
THE EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION SORTS
OF THINGS THAT HAVE EMPLOYED SO
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO MITIGATE
WITH AT LEAST AT. THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF ECONOMIC PAIN AS
POSSIBLE THAT'S AT LEAST FOR
THE SEAT. UP VERY MUCH OF THAT
AS WATER CLARITY. OF YEAH
BECAUSE OF GOOD NUYS THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION FROM THE APARTMENT
FINANCE AND ALSO FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST ABOUT THE
DURATION OF THAT. AND BOB THAT
IS SHORTER RATHER THAN LONGER
BUT IT'S VERY UNLIKELY TO BE A
SINGLE YEAR OF THAT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF THE A SHORTFALL
IN STATE REVENUES SO IN ALMOST
CERTAINLY WE ARE HAVING THE
SAME DISCUSSION. YEAR AND- BE
EVEN THE- SUBTLE I PLAN TO YOUR
IS A WISE THING TO DO. SO STE
QUESTION OF THE COMMUNITY.
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AT
THE CAL FRIEDMAN COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA WHEN COLLEGES DO NOT
HAVE A. YES GO AHEAD GREAT
THANK YOU AS I WAS MENTIONING
THE COMPANY CAN COLLEGES DO NOT
HAVE FEET SETTING AUTHORITY AND
THAT IS A RESPONSIBILITY THAT
FALLS WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE I
THESE. I WILL AFFECTED EIGHTY
OF THINGS IT WILL AFFECT THE
LEVEL OF PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT ARE OFFERED AT OUR
COLLEGES. ARE GIVEN THE- THAT
WERE SELECTED FOR CUTS ARE
LIKELY TO AFFECT AT
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT- THAT
IMPACT AT THE IN OUTBOX S. AND
MAY ALSO AFFECT. A WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS WHAT WE WILL DO TO TRY
TO MITIGATE THESE CUTS AS- WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY A
FLEXIBILITY IN AREAS WHERE IT
IS POSSIBLE. WE ALSO ASK THAT
UP MORE OF RESOURCES MAIN AT
THE LOCAL LAW SO THAT. WE ARE.
ACCESS TO THOSE AND- I IN ORDER
TO SERVE MORE STUDENTS AT THIS
TIME WE DON'T WANT TO REPEAT
THAT IT THAT THE ISSUES THAT WE
RAN INTO DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WHERE. WHERE STUDENTS
LOST ACCESS AT THE SAME TIME-
WE ARE EXPECTING A ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR CUT THESE
ARE EXTENSIVELY DEEP A MUCH
DEEPER THAN WE SAW DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION IN THAT SHORT.
OF A TIME. WELL WE WILL BUT WE-
BUT I THESE ARE GOING TO HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AND FORTUNATELY.
SO ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT WHEN
YOU SAY A LACK OF ACCESS YOU
TALKING ABOUT A DROP IN
ENROLLMENT. IT IT'S UNCERTAIN
WHAT WE WILL SEE AT THIS TIME-
WE DURING THE SOME OF OUR
CLOTHES CAN RELATED EXPENSES
WERE THOSE STUDENTS THAT HAD TO
UNFORTUNATELY PAS OUT OR DROP
OUT OF THEIR- MISSION. BECAUSE
THEY JUST NEEDED. TO ADAPT TO
THE CRISIS SO OUT WITH OUR
EXPENSES RELATED TO STUDENT FEE
REIMBURSEMENT AT SIX MIL M.
SIX. UP AND DAUGHTERS. ARE CALL
JUST DOING EVERYTHING THAT THEY
CAN PACKAGE THAT YOU RECEIVE
YOU THE IN. LATTER DAY IN BOTH
SUCCEED ON. OKAY AN- DO WE
CAN'T RECRUIT. IT'S BACK I AND
IN THAT THEY CAN READ READ
RETAIN THEIR PLAN FOR
EDUCATION. WE ALSO QUICKLY
TRANSITION TO DISTANCE
EDUCATION SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
OUR PROGRAMS AVAILABLE HERE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE ARM
PROGRAMS- SUCH AS C. T. E. IT
HARD TO CONVERT COURSES WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THESE
PROGRAMS REQUIRE OFTEN. CARRIED
LABS AND OTHER A SPACES. THAT
WE WILL NEED TO UTILIZE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND THEN WITH
REGARDS TO THE IMPACT OF ON
COLLEGES EACH WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT WAY OF ABSORBING THE
SOME OF THEM MAY HAVE BUILT OUT
RESERVISTS I CAN BE ADDRESS.
OTHERS WILL GET DIFFERENT
FINING SITUATE SHIN SO THE
IMPACT WILL HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
OF. THE IMPACT WILL BE VERY
DIFFERENT IN OUR HUNDRED FIFTY
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. OKAY THANK
YOU AND THE SAME QUESTION OF
THIS ISSUE OF THE UC POLICE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE OF
THE UC CAMPUSES HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THIS IS A NUMBER
FOUR LAST SEPTEMBER WE HAD
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
CORPS FRONT RESERVES THAT COULD
BE USED TO QUESTION. SOME BUT
WHICH ALREADY HAS IN ADDITION
TO UC REGENTS OUR MEETING
TOMORROW TO DISCUSS UP MULTI
PLAN FOR DEALING WITH A-
POTENTIAL STATE REDUCTION SENT
THE IMPACTS OF. NINETEEN ON
CAMPUSES. DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DEALT WITH. THE TRUCK FALLS WAS
BY PUTTING IN PLACE A HIRING
FREEZE A ALSO FOR HIM. IN A
TEAR MATTER WHERE EMPLOYEES
MAKING. LESS ANNUAL SALARY
WORKED FOR LOAD AT A LOWER
PERCENTAGE THAN EMPLOYEES
MAKING MORE FOR EXAMPLE
EMPLOYEES MAKING. FORTY
THOUSAND AND ONLY WERE FOR LOW
24% WHILE EMPLOYEES MAKING OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND WERE
FURLOUGHED AT 12% THOSE ARE
SOME POTENTIAL. A SECOND AT
THIS TIME AS WELL AT THIS POINT
OUR UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT PUBLICADO HAS PUT IN
PLACE A HIRING FREEZE FOR UC O.
P. AND AMEND THE CHANCELLOR'S
EIGHTY ARE HIRING SLOW DOWN TO
ONLY A CENTRAL ARE CRITICAL
POSSESSIONS OF IN ADDITION WE
HAVE PUT IN PLACE A SALARY FREE
FOR NON REPRESENT. STAFF THESE
UP COP IT IS THE POSSIBLE OF A
IN THE SPORT THE OF OUR FACULTY
EXCEPT FOR MERIT PROGRAM WHICH
WERE REQUIRED LOS THAT HAVE THE
NINETEEN EIGHT EIGHT- GEN OR
PRESIDENT USED ON VOLUNTARY 10%
WHICH IS NOT A BIG SAVINGS FOR
A AS A BUT- SHE- THERE
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO ELIMINATING
ALL NON IS AS TRAVEL. AND FREE
TO GO CERTAIN UP CONTRACT
AGREEMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A AND ONE FINAL QUESTION WELL
I'VE GOT THE UC HERE. IS A-
BRING YOUR PLANS FOR FALL
INSTRUCTION- IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER A RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION ARE YOU GOING TO.
PERSIST AND DISTANCE LEARNING
AS A GOING TO BE SO. HM
CONTEMPLATING DOING THAT ON. A
SYSTEM WIDE BASIS RDHA CAMPUS
BY SPACES. ARE REGENTS WILL BE
LOOKING AT THAT DURING THEIR
MEETING HAPPENING TOMORROW AND
THE DAY AFTER WE ARE WAITING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON WHAT IS A SAFE WAY
FOR UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
REPOPULATE. BUT SAYS. IT'S ARE
UP AT THE MOMENT. PLEASE START
WITH OF GRADUATE COURSES WHERE
ESPECIALLY LABORATORIES WHERE
INDIVIDUALS CAN HAVE MORE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND BRING
THOSE STUDENTS BACK ON CAMPUS
FIRST BUT LIKE I SAID WE'RE
WAITING FOR OUR OFFICIAL
GUIDANCE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH SO WE CAN DO IT. IN THIS
WAY. THANK YOU BYE. THANK
MISTER CHAIRMAN. OKAY THANK YOU
SOMEONE EMILY MONTH THANK YOU
AT THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR THE
PRESENTATION I HAVE. I WAS
WORKING FOR HIGHER ED IN OUR
LAST RECESSION AND KNOW WHAT
THAT FEELS LIKE IT KNOWS WHAT
THE PREPARATION OF LEADING UP
UNTIL YOU KNOW TO YOU DID GOING
TO BE EFFORT. BUT ALL FEELS I'M
THE GROUND AND THEY'RE
DEFINITELY. AS EXPECTATIONS
DIDN'T CHANGE MUCH BUT WORKLOAD
FOR AT THE HIGHER END TEAM AND
I'M CERTAINLY DID AND MORE WAS
EXPECTED- WITH LESS AND- I FEEL
FOR WHAT'S ABOUT TO COME I KNOW
THE FEELING AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT STRUCK THE TIME WAS.
BUT JUST TRY. OUT HOW SOME OF
THIS WAS IMPACTING STUDENTS AND
I REMEMBER A STUDENTS COMING TO
ME STUDENTS BEING STRESSED OUT
ABOUT THEY HAVE THEM HAVING TO
WORK MORE AND TO BE TO AFFORD
IT AT THE SAME LEVEL OF THE OF
EDUCATION. THEY WERE YOU KNOW.
MONTHS BUT HE L. AS THE THING
FOR EXPENSIVE. I REMEMBER. THE
CHALLENGES- NOT JUST TO THE
STUDENTS BUT TO THE FAMILIES TO
THE STAFF OF THE YOU KNOW THE
STREAMLINING OF SERVICES WHICH
TRANSLATES TO SOMETIME LAST
STAFF- A IN IN TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT DEPARTMENTS THAT YOU MORE.
SOME OF THE KIND OF HIS WORK OR
NOT AND FIGURES TIME RETIRED
GRANT INCENTIVE PROGRAMS ALL
THAT STUFF- ARE THINGS THEY
THINK ABOUT BUT DOT AS- A NEED
I'M I THINK DESIRE OUT OF A
NEED WITH A LOT SESSION AND- GO
INTO THE- MAKING IN BACK SO
WHAT WHAT THE BENEFITS. FEEL
LIKE FIRST THING I KNOW I'M-
THE RIGHT. THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
TO HAVE BEEN. ME IN IN A BE
ABLE TO DO A ACTUAL FULL STAY
BUT SOME SHORT TERM AND IT IS
ON WHAT THIS IS TO MEAN FIRST.
IN A THIS. AND I'D ACTUALLY
LIKE TO ASK WHEN I OF FINANCE
AND STATE INTO IT TO ASK. TO
THINK ABOUT THAT IN ONE OF OUR
LAST BUT HEARINGS WE TAUGHT IN
KATY TWELVE ROLLED I'M ABOUT TO
LEARN. THAT LOOK LIKE IT WILL
IDENTIFY SO WHAT IS THAT LOOK
LIKE FOR HIGHER. I'M AND FINING.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE FINANCE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE WHAT ARE
THE- EDUCATIONAL AND LEARNING
TRADE OFFS AND IF THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED BY AGAIN DO F. AND-
EACH SEGMENT THAT WOULD BE. AS
TO KNOW THANK. SURE RIGHT I
THINK THE IT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES PERSPECTIVE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PERSPECTIVE OUR OVERARCHING
GOAL IS TO- ITEMIZE ACCESS AND
MINIMIZE IMPACTS ON EQUITY. OF
WHICH ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON SO
FOR PUTTING. WE ARE TRYING TO
PROPOSE- AND WE HAVE PROPOSED
AN ARM SHOULD MAKE REVISION-
HOLDING CAL GRANTS- CONSTANT
AND MAKING NO CHANGES FULLY
FUNDING WITHOUT THE PROGRAM.
ALL NOT WITHSTANDING COMMENTS
BY IT. GALLAGHER AND A MEMBER
MEDINA. AND WE CERTAINLY ARE
ALSO INCLUDING BUDGETARY
LANGUAGE I AM DIRECTING THE CSU
ON THE YOU'VE GOT YOU SEE TO
ARE ALSO- NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT-
ACCESS TO STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES AND STUDENT ACCESS FOR
UNDER. JEANS AT THE UC AND YES
YOU DO A- IN AN ACT THE
REDUCTION IN THE- STUDENTS
CENTER FUNDING FORMULA WILL WE
ARE ASKED THE COLLEGES JUNE THE
IMPACT ON ACCESS UP FOR
STUDENTS UP WITH ALSO
MAINTAINED- THE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS FOR OUR OUR MIDDLE
INCOME. CALIFORNIANS MAINLY
HELP MAKE COLLEGE BONDS GRANTS
AS WELL AS THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM WELL WITH
THAT IT'S ALL HOW CAN WE HELP
STUDENTS UP HE BOTH AS AN
ACCESSIBLE AT THE UNIVERSE
WHICH WE KNOW WILL BE
CHALLENGING. FOR THE FIRST
CAUCUS SHINGLES BUT CERTAINLY
WORTH TO MAXIMIZE THE
EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS IN A
MORE GLOBAL SCALE BUT THE MADE
PROVISION DOES ASK THE SEGMENTS
TO LOOK AT HOW THEY CAN
IMPROVE- THE OFFERINGS- AND THE
QUALITY AND THE AVAILABILITY OF
THEIR ON LINE PROGRAMS CHIU
FOCUSED ON- IN OUR CALIFORNIA
ST STE. AT CHAU CERTAINLY AT
THE- VERY ACTIVE WORK WERE
ATTEMPTING TO DO ALL THAT WE
CAN UP FOR STUDENTS OUT WITH
THE TRYING TIMES YOU KNOW THERE
ARE ARE. BEFORE AND REDUCTION
OF VERY TO BALANCE THE BUDGET.
I THANK GOD OUR KEPT YESTERDAY
MR OF THIS ONE AND THEN-
COMMUNICATED THE IN ROD A
SENATE HEARING THAT THE
GOVERNOR REFER TO MANY OF THESE
ON. REDUCTIONS AS PART BECAUSE
THEY THEY HAVE A LOT OF PROMISE
FOR. MORE IS FOR STUDENTS FOR
HIGH EDUCAION SYSTEM. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M I'M
GONNA TAKE A TIME OUT FROM-
SUMMARILY MOANS QUESTIONING
EXACT ANY TO GO ACTUALLY
PRESENT THE BILL IN A FEW
SECONDS I HAVE A UP QUITE A FEW
QUESTIONS ALL SEVEN GET
THROUGH- SON AND THEN LOCAL
BACK SO YOU CAN STAY THERE TO
HAVE SOME FINANCE GROUPS AND
SO- YEAH THEY'RE VERY. COLD
DECISION AS YOU SAID YESTERDAY
IN THEM K. TWELVE EARLY
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE DEBATE YOU KNOW WE'RE
LOOKING TO MITIGATE THESE
WHETHER IT'S TO. LOOK FOR OTHER
CREATIVE WAYS OR TAKE THEM OFF
THE BOOKS ENTIRELY I DON'T
THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
NECESSARILY- YOU KNOW GIVING IN
AND THINKING WERE UNDER THE GUN
HAVE THESE TRIGGERS BECAUSE-
THEY THINK IT'S- A THAT. WORK
TO BE DONE THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS. ON THIS FRONT CERTAINLY
IT WOULD ALL GO AWAY IN GEORGIA
BUT FOR THIS YEAR'S CATS WITH
AN ACTION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DON'T. LOOK THAT BAD
OR OTHER THIS IS. NOT THE OWNER
TO YOU ABOUT. IS THE LA OKAY
OUTLINE. SOME OF THESE OTHER
REALLY CREATE OPTION AND
FRANKLY- I THINK THERE AS I
SAID YESTERDAY I THOUGHT THERE
PROBABLY WERE MORE OPTIONS LIKE
THIS AND HIGHER THAN THERE ARE
IN K. TWELVE AND EARLY AT LIKE
WE DIDN'T SEE ANY. NOT ANY
THERE WEREN'T AS MANY OPTIONS
YESTERDAY- WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT SOME OF THESE- SO WE
WON'T HAVE TO DO THIS ARBITRARY
10% ACROSS THE BOARD. WHICH
WOULD HAVE A MORE NEGATIVE
IMPACT FRANKLY ON STUDENTS- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF IDEAS HERE I'M
STRUGGLING WITH HIM ONE BY ONE
JUST AND- WE'RE ALL BIG. THERE
IS IT THE MISTRESS OPENNESS.
THINGS I THINK WE'RE OPEN TO A
DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- WITHIN TE CONTEXT
OF OUR OVERARCHING FRAMEWORK
WHICH IS THAT WE ARE NOT-
TAKING ACTIONS THAT. LEAD TO-
JUST PUSHING OUT OF THE FISCAL
SITUATION IN CHIU FUTURE UP
BUDGET YEARS- SO WE CERTAINLY-
MESSAGE THAT IN OUR
INTRODUCTION CHAPTER- AT THAT
SAID. WE DO TO SUPPORT- MANY
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
AND I THINK WE WOULD WE WOULD
BE REMISS IF WE DIDN'T SAY WE
WOULDN'T. I CERTAINLY RECOMMEND
BEING VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT THE
CHOICES THAT WE MAKE YES WERE
OPEN TO. ADJUST BUT THE
LEGISLATURE AS JUNE WE CAN BASS.
PEOPLE MEANT. ANY ACTIONS
NEEDED TO INSURE THAT WE MAY A
BALANCED BUDGET- IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY OKAY I ALSO WANT
TO TALK. TO YOU ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL FOR CALIBRATE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I KNOW. IT'S
ONE PIECE IS NOT A PANACEA IS
NOT GOING TO SOLVE IT BUT- I
THINK AS MR MEDINA AT NOTED IN
SOME OF THE OTHER COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS SOMETHING IT'S GOT OUR
INTERESTS IT WAS LAW PROMOTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THROUGH THIS CURRENT EMPIRE
GOVERNOR BUT THEN AT. THAT
FASTER. FRANKLY AWAY OF MONEY
ALL THE PROMISES THAT WERE LAID
UP HERE THEY'VE ALL GONE INTO
THE TRASH CAN. THAT YOU HAVE X.
AMOUNT OF. STUDENTS FROM THIS
SECTOR AND THE IDEAL WITH SEIU
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES IN THERE IS
JUST LESS THAN A DOZEN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ACTUALLY. END UP WHEN
IT ACTUALLY WENT ONLINE SO. IT
REALLY IS- YOU KNOW THROWING-
GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD I'M BRING
THAT SAYING BUT LIKE THROWING
MONEY AWAY. SO THAT IS WE DO
NOW. ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OR NEW. AND THEY'RE GRADUALLY
GETTING BETTER NOW DOING IT
FRANKLY BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING
FORCED TO SO WE HAVE- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY HAVE ALL
THESE CAMPUSES DO IT NOT
REINVENT THE WHEEL SO ARE YOU
FINALLY WILLING- ON COMING TO
THE REALIZATION THAT MAYBE
THERE'S A BETTER WAY ALLOCATE
THIS MONEY TO THE CAMPUS DO
THAT ON ENDEAVOR. AT THIS TIME
THE POSITION TO SUPPORT. FOR
THE REDUCTIONS IN THE BUDGET
FOR THE CALIBRATED- WE ARE
AWARE THAT THEY RECENTLY- HIRED
A NEW PRESIDENT THAT WE EXPECT
TO DELIVER ON THE PROMISES OF
THE COLLEGE- AS WELL AS TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR OUR RESIDENTS.
THE FORMULA UP THAT THAT HAVE.
MANY OF WHICH HAVE ARE IMPACTED
TO BY THE- RECESSION- DRIVEN BY
COOK BUT NINETY. YEAH I THINK
THAT THERE IS THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN BY CAMEL REALIZATION
THAT YOU KNOW WE SEE THIS THE
TOP WILL SWALLOW LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND YOU KNOW PROBLEM IS
MADE PROMISES NOT KEPT A NEW
ERA OF THE COMMUNIQUE IS ONE
THING IS NOT THE ONLY NINE
UNDERGRAD CAN'T ACROSS. YOUR
CSU. THERE'S A COMMUNITY.
MISTER GALLAGHER IS AREA AND
OBERNOLTE IN RURAL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA THERE ISN'T THE
THOUGHT DESERT'S OF NO ACCESS
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE CAMPUSES AND THEY
HAVE- OFF CENTER CAMPUSES SO
REALLY AT THAT HE IS NO NEED
ANYMORE TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
ON THAT SO. WE WILL CERTAINLY
HAVE A PURPLE AND I'M SURE THE
SENATE WILLIS OFF- I WENT TO-
BREAK UP- I KNOW IT'S HARD
GOING BACK AND FORTH BUT MAYBE
YOU SEE. THE QUESTION OF YOU
YES DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE MASCOT
IS FOR CALGARY. IS THIS A TRICK
QUESTION NOW IT'S AN HONEST
QUESTION I DO NOT KNOW THE
QUESTION THE QUESTION IS THE
MASCOT OF CALIBRATE CALLERS I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS ONE.
JUST A QUESTION. ALL RIGHT HE-
WELL WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T ASK
THOSE TOUGH QUESTIONS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO I THINK.
OKAY THAT WAS A GOOD ONE MR
O'DONNELL. SO HOPEFULLY WE'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE TO GO THERE BUT
IF THER WAS A 10% ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR UC IS THERE ANY
INDICATION OF HOW THE OFFICE
THE PRESIDENT AND THE KEY SAYS
WOULD IMPLEMENT THAT- TO BE
PROPORTIONAL. WHERE ARE YOU IN
THIS IN THIS STAGE. AT THIS
POINT THE REGION'S HAVE NOT
DECIDED HOW THEY WOULD
IMPLEMENT A 10% REDUCTION TO
ALL OF THE CAMPUS AS CURRENTLY
OUR STATE GENERAL FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE CAMPUSES
BASED ON THEIR- A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT. ENROLLMENT AND OF A
10% REDUCTION IF IT WAS PUT
THROUGH THE MODEL WOULD TO
MOVED TO THE CAMPUS AND IN A
SIMILAR MANNER BASED ON THIRD
WORLD. GOTCHA AND THEN BASED
UPON THE THEIR RESERVES AND
THE- MONIES IN THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT THAT WE TALK
ABOUT A COUPLE YEARS AGO. THE
INITIATIVES AND SO FORTH. HOW
MUCH HOW MUCH IT ON THE TABLE
IS THAT AS FAR AS A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT ARE FROM THE
REGION'S TO UTILIZE THOSE
RESOURCES AND NOT IMPACT. CAN'T
WRAPS UNFORTUNATELY SIR- DO
THAT THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
STATE AUDITOR THAT WE UTILIZE
OF THE RESERVES THE PAPER
CAMPUS OPERATIONS AND TRANSFER
THOSE FUNDS TO CAMPUSES THAT
HAS NOT BEEN COMPLETED AND WILL
BE FULL DONE OF AT THE END OF.
THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR JUNE.
TWENTY TWENTY ARGUES THE O. P.
HAS ALREADY A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT HEADING
INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
BEFORE THE- A 10% CUT. SO THERE
ARE NO FUNDS TO AND FROM THE
OKAY RESERVES TO BE PROVIDED
THE CAMPUSES UNFORTUNATELY I'M
I THINK IT'S KIND OF APPLES AND
ORANGES I'M NOT SURE WHEN IT.
GET IN THE WEEDS RIGHT HERE BUT
THAT'S NOT QUITE ACCURATE AT IT
IS A VIçT THOSE TYPE OF
PROGRAMS THE CAMPUSES. BUT
THERE WERE OTHER INITIATIVES
THAT ARE RUN THROUGH THE OFF TO
THE PRESS AND- LEAD. YOUR MARKS
THAT WE HAVE BROUGH WITH THE LA
HOW THE AUDITOR ADDING UP TO
THAT. NO LOW HUNG LONG IS A
DOLLARS AND- WE THINK THEY'RE
STILL NOT TO LOOK FOR POTENTIAL
THIRTY REDUCTIONS SO YOU WON'T
HAVE THE IMPACT MUCH AS
STUDENTS OF THE CAMPUS WILL.
AND I AFTER. THAT MY BILLS IN A
SECOND SO- MAYBE I CAN COME
BACK A BIT LATER BUT I WANTED
TO JUST MENTION AND THIS IS A
REALLY FOR YOU SEE BUT FOR YOU.
TO YOU AS A WHOLE JUST KIND OF
THE COMMENTS ON STUDENT FEES I
THINK WE NEED TO BE REALISTIC
THAT. FOR EXAMPLE THE UC WE
FIND WE'VE BEEN IT THROUGH
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT STUDENT
FEE REVENUE AND- NON RESIDENT.
AND CSU IT'S MAINLY- STUDENT
FEE SUPPORT AND GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT AND CELLS YOU KNOW
THOSE ARE THE TWO OR THREE
LIKE. THE LEGS OF THE STOOL.
AND SO. THE MAJORITY OF CSU
STUDENTS DAHLE PASSED IN PEACE
ANYWAY. AND SO MAY TIMES WERE
SUBSIDIZING UPPER MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES- SO THAT'S A POLICY
CHOICE WE HAVE TO MAKE AND SO
BY. BY FREEZING IT WE CAN SAY
OKAY WE YOU KNOW PAT OURSELVES
ON THE BACK NO INCREASES I GET
THAT. BUT THAT LIMITS ACCESS
FOR ENROLLING MORE STUDENTS TO
CANNELLA HAVING A LITTLE
BROTHER OR SISTER NEIGHBOR GET
INTO THIS YES YOU ARE YOU SEE
SO. I THINK WE NEED TO REALIZE
THAT AND THERE'S NO I THINK IT
THREE WHERE THERE IS ALWAYS A
CAP. ON ON ON FEES WE LOOK AT
YOUR CABLE BILL YOUR YOUR RENT
AND SO FORTH HAVING MODERATE
AND PREDICTABLE INCREASES LET'S
SET IT. ON AVERAGE WITH THE CPI
AND SO FORTH IS I THINK NOT
UNREASONABLE SO. AS NOT OUR
DECISION IS UP TO THE REGION'S
IMAGE AND THE AND THE TRUSTEES
WE CONTROL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FEES BUT I JUST THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BE AT THE STATE.
REALISTIC THAT THE SAVING OF
INCREASES THE MATTER HOW- IT'S
THE ARE HAVE. SO WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO. TURN ME OVER TO MR
MEDINA FOR A FEW MOMENTS. AND
WE HAVE A FEW MORE QUESTIONS
FROM SOMEONE MEMBER LEE MON AND
IF ANY OTHERS WANT TO ENGAGE
AND THEN WE'LL GET TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS THANK YOU. BOB. FIVE
THIRTY THE PHONES ARE GOING TO
TURN OFF. SO. BY THE END OF THE
WE'LL TRY TO SLEEP ON. I
STARTED ASKING I THINK THAT THE
INITIAL I WAS FOR BOTH THE
SECOND AND DEAL AT AND THEN
HOPING THAT THE SEGMENTS- AND-
AND FOR THE PEACE. ABOUT WHAT
THE LOS BEFORE THE IMPACT IS
GOING TO BE FOR STUDENTS GIVEN
THE PROPOSED BUDGET. SINCE I'M
SITTING RIGHT HERE I'LL TAKE
THE QUESTION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAMONT- WERE
VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF INSTRUCTION FOR
STUDENTS EXPOSURE LEE AS THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC CRISIS
CONTINUES AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH IN FINANCIAL LOSSES THE UC
SYSTEM WILL HAVE TO BEAR IN OUR
OTHER AREAS. SO WE'RE VERY WORK
OUT OF THE QUALITY OF
INSTRUCTION IF WE CONTINUE TO
LOSE FUNDING. AT THIS POINT WE
ARE PUTTING EMPHASIS ON STUDENT
SAFETY AND THIS IS WHY WE HAVE
MOVED TO REMOTE INSTRUCTION ON
ALL OUR CAMPUSES. AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT HOW TO SAFELY RE
POPULATE OUR CAMPUSES AND BRING
STUDENTS BACK FOR THAT UP ON
CAMPUS EXPERIENCE. I'LL HAND IT
OVER TO SEE US YOU KNOW UNLESS
YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
FOR ME. I DO SO WHAT DO YOU
HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT. A
CHANGING QUALITY COULD LOOK
LIKE. CHANGING QUALITY COULD BE
FEWER LECTURERS BEING HIRED-
FOR FOLLOWING TERMS IT WOULD
MEAN. LONGER POTENTIAL WAIT
LIST FOR CERTAIN MAJORS- IT
COULD MEAN FEWER COURSES GRADE
MORE BOTTLENECKS AND CAUSING
STUDENTS TO TAKE LONGER TO
GRADUATE ONE OF THE THINGS THE
UC SYSTEM HAS REALLY BEEN
WORKING ON ITS OF. ELIMINATING
BOTTLENECKS IN MAJOR SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN GRADUATE FASTER BY
HAVING STUDENTS GRADUATE FASTER
RATHER THAN GRADUATING IN FIVE
AND A HALF YEARS OF IF WE GET
THEM TO GRADUATE IN FOUR AND A
HALF OR FOUR YEARS THEY TAKE ON
LESS DEBT AND THEY MOVE INTO
THE WORK FORCE FASTER. SO A
STUDENT MAY HAVE TO BE ENROLLED
LONGER IF WE HAVE TO CUT BACK
ON THE NUMBER OF COURSE
OFFERINGS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH. ALWAYS SORRY FOR THE
DELAY THERE'S A LONG ON RAMP
HERE FOR THAT TESTIMONY OF ALL
OF IT SO THAT'S WHY TAKES WELL
FIRST TO GET GET INVOLVED HERE
ARE FROM SEASONSPERSPECTIVE I
THINK- MY COLLEAGUE FROM YOU
SEE NAILED IT ON THE HEAD TERMS
OF MOST ISSUES WE DEAL WITH
WELL I THINK I'D LIKE TO ADD-
IS A DISTINCTION. BETWEEN WHAT
WOULD BE THE SHORT TERM IN THE
LONG TERM I THINK WHAT- IS
MISTER TANYA FROM UC WAS
TALKING ABOUT WAS A LITTLE BIT
LONGER TERM FOR US IT WOULD BE
MORE OF A- WILL IF WE HAVE
SUSTAINED. RECURRING ONGOING
COST YEAR AFTER YEAR THAT WE
ARE GONNA PROBABLY HALF
PRESSURES ON A ROLE THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE- DIFFICULT IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE HIGHER ALL THE
FACT THAT THE WE NEED TO SERVE
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS SO THAT'S A
LONGER TERM AND SHORT TERM I
THINK- LIKE I SAID EARLIER I
THINK WE- ARE. PRETTY WELL
EQUIPPED TO WHETHER A- VERY
IMMEDIATE STORE. SO THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO UTILIZE OUR FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE RESERVES OTHERS A
QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT THE
LEVEL OF RESERVES THAT- YOU SEE
HAD ALL JUST- I'LL JUST PROVIDE
YOU OURS. WE'VE SOCKED AWAY
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS SYSTEM
WIDE FOR TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
IN OUR OPERATING FUND THAT'S
THE INSTRUCTION AND THAT IT
MEAN. TO SUPPORT US UP AND
EIGHT SO. I BE REMISS IN.
TELLING YOU THAT IF- YOU
DECIDED THAT- WELL THAT'S THE
AMOUNT YOU COULD CUT THAT THE
C. ISSUE THAT WOULD BE THE
INAPPROPRIATE RESPONSE BECAUSE
UP AS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
STATED- WE ARE PROBABLY IN FOR
THREE OR FOUR YEAR PERIOD
SIGNIFICANT- ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
AND THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
YOUR TWO F. F. YOU NEEDED TO
DIVE IN AND WANT TO CUT AT THE
UNIVERSITY A DEEPER. ONE OTHER
THING I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT TO
YOU. IS THAT RATHER THAN THE-
THAT NEGATIVE IMPACT OF
STUDENTS ON THE MEDIAN. ON THE
IMMEDIATE FRONT ALLEGE A LITTLE
OUT OF TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT OUR CAMPUSES- ARE
GENERALLY DOING. AS AN
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN SO. OBVIOUSLY ALL OF
OUR ALL OF OUR- CAMPUSES WERE
IN PRETTY QUICK DISARRAY RIGHT
WITH STUDENTS DECIDING TO LEAVE
CAMPUS THERE ARE STUDENT
HOUSING AND- YOU KNOW WEST WITH
SWITCHING TO- ONLINE. FORMAT
WITH SEVENTY THOUSAND- COURSES
BEING CONVERTED IMMEDIATELY TO
THE VIRTUAL MALL BUT ALLERGY-
ONE THING THAT REALLY WAS.
FANTASTIC TO SEE AND HEAR AND
EVEN. WAS AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AS WELL. WAS THAT. WHEN
STUDENTS NEEDED ACCESS TO. OUR
HEART- SOFTWARE TO LICENSES
INTERACT CONNECTIVITY- OUR
CAMPUSES STEPPED UP BIG. THE
STEP THE BIG IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING WIFI ACCESS AFFECTED
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE IF FULLER TED.
I THEY EXPANDED. ACCESS AND
LOTS OF STUDENTS COULD DRIVE IN
THE CAMPUS PARK IN THE PARKING
LOT AND HAVE GREAT INTERNET
ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO- DEAL WITH
THIS- THIS CRISIS A LITTLE BIT
UNIQUELY BUT STILL BE ABLE
THAT- TO DEAL WITH AT. BE
INVOLVED IN THE COURSE WORK IN.
RECEIVE OTHER SERVICES. YES I
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A LITTLE SITUATION
WITH THE TIME HERE. AND SO I AM
AMY I HATE TO DO THIS BUT I'M
GONNA HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF AND
SEE IF WE COULD JUST GET TO THE
FINAL ONE NO IT'S OKAY. IT'S
YOU'RE NOT SEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE A JUST HAVE AN-
ISSUE WITH THE TIMING. AND SO I
THINK WE JUST NEED ONE MORE
SECTOR- TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
AND THEN. GIVEN OUR OUR
SITUATION AT THE TIME I'M GOING
TO MOVE IT PASSED TO THE NEXT.
A MEMBER BUT I THINK I THINK
YOU FOR THAT AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR HAVING TO CUT YOU OFF.
GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
LIGHTNING SPEED ROUND JUST
BECAUSE OF OUR TIME CONSTRAINT.
SOME EARLY NOT. I THAT'S ONE OF
THE MEN THAT THE IMPACT WILL BE
VERY DIFFERENT ACROSS OUR
SEVENTY THREE DISTRICTS- AS YOU
KNOW THERE LOCALLY GOVERNED SO
THEY WILL HAVE TO IDENTIFY WAYS
TO MITIGATE THESE CUTS LOCALLY
BUT IN THE PAST AND WHAT WE MAY
SEE WHERE I OVER BILLION DOLLAR
COTTON ONE YEAR IS ATTRITION
LARGER CLASS SIZES ARE AND
GROWING BASIC NEEDS FOR
STUDENTS AS YOU RECALL- WE
ENTERED THIS. THIS RECESSION
WHICH- SIR THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT HAS NOT
CHANGED IF ANYTHING COPA
NINETEEN EXPOSE THE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL DISPARITIES THAT OUR
STUDENTS FACE OUT WE ALSO WILL
HAVE PRESSURES ON ACCESS- AND
SO AS YOU- AS AT THE LEGISLATOR
INNER LET IT LEGISLATURE IN
CONSIDER OPTIONS MOVING FORWARD
WE DO WHAT AGAIN FLEX THE IN
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN COVER
YOU DIDN'T OF RESOURCES TO STE
MORE. BUT I LIMITED RESOURCES
WE ALL ASK THAT ON THAT YOU
LIMIT PRACTICE THAT USE ME AS A.
THROUGH TWO OTHER. IN OTHER
TWELVE OUT TO THE AND THAT YOU
ALSO LOOK AT LIMITING ON FOR ME
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. MR MURATSUCHI. YEAH YOU
ALSO HAVE IN WHAT MANY CALL THE
QUESTION THOUGH OF. YEAH NUMBER.
THERE. I ALSO HAD A QUESTION
FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND SO
WOULD APPRECIATE TO MS THE
NEVER ENDING. POLITICS FOR THAT
NO I DIDN'T HAVE MY MIKE ON SO.
BY HI I HAVE A CURRENT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM IN
TORRANCE IN MY DISTRICT AND-
THEY SHARED WITH ME THAT-
THEY'RE HAVING THEY THEY THEY
CAN'T CONDUCT MANY OF THEIR C.
T. E. CLASSES BECAUSE THEIR C.
T. ARM THAT THAT THE NATURE OF
C. T. PROGRAMS INVOLVES
STUDENTS HAVING TO BE. THERE IN
THE CLASSROOM TO WORK ON
MATERIALS WORK ON DEVELOPING-
THEIR HANDS ON SKILLS ARE HAS
THAT BEEN A CHALLENGE IN TERMS
OF THE COMMUNICABLE INCHES
IMPLEMENTING YOU KNOW BIG
CONTINUING THIS C. T. CLASSES.
IN THIS STATE HOME ORDER PERIOD.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CITY-
WE SHARE THAT SAME CONCERN
THAT- YOU HAVE AND WE WERE
JOINED BY OVER SEVENTY
ORGANIZATIONS. MONTH LAST FOUR
RESOURCE STAYS AN ONLINE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT OUR
COLLEGES BUT ALSO RESOURCE TO
HELP US CONVERT THESE AGAIN
HARD TO CONVERT CD CLASSES WILL
BE. RIGHT THERE ARE A VERY.
WITH CUTS ESPECIALLY TO WORK
PROGRAMS WE ARE CONCERNED
OPTIONS AGAIN THAT ARE
PRESENTED TO YOU THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER- ARE SHIFTING
AT LOCAL READ SPLIT. MORE
STRONG WORK FORCE REMAIN LOOK.
AT WE CAN USE A VERY LIMITED
FUNDS- TO TRY TO CONVERT CLASS
AS AN N. RIVAS THE SPACE. SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE OFFERING
THEM SOMETHING YOUR CONCERN
SPECIALLY WHEN THE LAW THESE
CUTS IN SO WHEN YOU TALK
CONTENT THE CITY PRO. IT HALF.
THEIR HOME OR BE LIFTED. SO
THIS PROGRAM CAN OF HAVE A
TREND TO RECALL LAW BUT NOT ALL
OF THEM CAN OTHERS HAVE
CONTINUED ON CAMPUS AT A YOU
CAN YOU KNOW VERY USE AGAINST
IN ROOM WITH DISTANCING IN
FISCAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
AND IN WAY THAT MAINTAIN SAFETY
SO I AND IT WAS VERY EXPENSIVE
YOU. WE WILL BE. IF YOU TO.
CURRENTLY THANK THAT'S- BUNCH.
THANK YOU WE ARE NOT GOING TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
BEFORE I BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT
ALSO ONE OUT THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING A RED WRITTEN BACK AT
BUDGET TO. ASSEMBLY DOT
CALIFORNIA DOT GOV EMAIL
ACCOUNT ANY EMAILS THAT WE
RECEIVED BY THE CLOSE OF
BUSINESS TODAY WILL BE COMPILED
AND SENT TO ALL MEMBERS HERE
AND TO MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE. SO I A MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT FOLKS ARE
ON THE LINE AND I WILL OPENED
IT UP BEFORE I DO I WANT TO SAY
DUE TO OUR TIME CONSTRAINTS.
I'M IN A LIMIT OF PUBLIC
COMMENTS TO AROUND THIRTY
SECONDS AND I WILL BE STRICT ON
THAT SO PLEASE KEEP IT VERY
BRIEF- AND WE WILL BEGIN THE
MODERATORS ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. FIRST WE'LL
GO TO THE LINE NUMBER TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB IS JEFF
THE CARNEGIE ERA CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. OKAY MIKE THIRTY
MINUTE COMEDY I'M AN ADVOCATE
BY WHAT YOU KNOW WHY. SHOULD WE
SAY RECESSIONARY PERIOD OF
DISTILLING GET DISABILITY SIR
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED PLEASE SEE
THAT THE UFC OR LOCAL FEDERAL
AID OPERATION. IS FUNDED. YOU
LOOK AT YOUR FUNDING AND YOUR
OTHER DISAPPEARS SUBJECT
MATTERS- PLEASE DO IT WITH THE
SITE AS YOU SAY OF THREE YEARS
IN ADVANCE WALK BACK WITH
TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT WHAT'S
YOUR BEST DECISIONS YOU CAN
MAKE. FOR HIGHER EDUCATION. AND
AGAIN THANK YOU GUYS STONE GOOD
TO EDUCATION A GOOD TO LISTEN
TO YOU BUT PLEASE BUT THE
DISABILITY OR THE LOCAL
SATELLITE OPERATION THAT IS.
PROVIDED YOUR INTERNSHIPS- WELL
WITH THE CHAIN FROM IT AFTER
THAT MAKE TO WHAT POLICIES THAT
ARE GOING ON. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND. THAT WAS THIRTY
SECONDS NOT. THANK YOU. STE
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU ARE
COURTING LINE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAIR MEMBERS
KELLY BEING REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE THAN
FIFTY THOUSAND POSITION
MEMBERS. WE ARE RELIEVED TO SEE
THE CONTINUATION OF THE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM FUNDED BY THE PROPERTY
SIX TOBACCO TAX REVENUE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
AGAIN PROVIDE THE SMALL BACK
BILL TO ENSURE THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM SETTING HAVE MORE
CERTAINTY THE PROGRAM
MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM AT THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL. WE
ASK HAT THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
CONFIRM THE- TO FUND THE
PROPERTY SIX GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM AT THE FORTY
MILLION LEVEL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA FOR MAKING THE
COMMENT ABOUT. RESIDENCY
PROGRAM TO ADD YOU SEE OUR AD-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU GUYS STRAIGHT BUT YOU'RE
PROP THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LARA
BARBECUE THAT'S WHAT THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
EXACTLY EVEN BEFORE CO THAT
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA STUDENT
STRUGGLED WITH COLLEGE COSTS
AND BASIC NEEDS AND THE CRISIS
HAS MADE THINGS FAR WORK MAKING
INVESTMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND NEED BASED FINANCIAL AID
AND THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY ALL THE MORE
CRITICAL THAN ENSURING STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO TRULY EQUITABLE
AFFORDABLE COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY.
IN ADDITION TO SHIELD AND CAL
GRANT FROM CUTS THAT WOULD
DEVASTATE UNDER RESOURCE
CALIFORNIANS THERE SEVERAL
NARROW REFORM THE LEGISLATURE
CAN ACT TO HELP PROTECT CURRENT
FINANCIAL AID RECIPIENTS.
INCLUDING EXTENDING THE TIME
PERIOD DURING ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS CAN RECEIVE A
TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT
AND WAVING COMMITTEE SERVICE
FIREMEN DURING ST MARTIN PEEPER
DREAMER SERVER AND A GRANT.
RECIPIENT MORE DETAILS
AVAILABLE IN THE WRITTEN
COMMENTS ACTIVATED THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TIME AND.
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. NECK
CALLER. YOUR ACTUAL BOTTLE I
NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO ALL OF THEM
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION TWENTY FOUR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE JOINED OUR
LETTER OUTLINING AT BUDGET
PRIOR THE FRIEND DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. FOR THE NINETEEN AND
THE IMMINENT THE CREAM COURT
RULING OF THE FUTURE YEAH TO
OFFSET UNDOCUMENTED ELIGIBILITY
FOR KAREN BACK ON THE COURT WE
ASK. CONSIDER PROVIDING FIVE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARD A ONE TIME FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR INCREASE THE GRANT THE
STUDENT. BY THE FUNDED BY THE
CARE ACT AND WE DID NOT RECEIVE
STATE AND MAINTAIN THE NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FUNDING
ALLOCATION FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE SERVICE TWENTY. GRANT AN
INTERPRETATION OF THE PLAYING
COURT RULING ON .COM WE OFFER
URGE THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
TOWARD NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
FROM CATHOLIC STUDENTS STAFF
AND FACULTY AFTER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ARE FACING THE SAME
CHALLENGES OF APPEARANCE BUT
WITH YOUR LIFE THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR CALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER YOU WILL GO TO
WHATEVER PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
TAKE REMERON TO HAPPEN TO
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AS YOU KNOW THE
CARS ACT OF THE WHO DID
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FROM
AMERICAN GATE AND PROVIDED
LITTLE RELIEF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RELATIVE TO MEET THAT
THEIR STUDENTS. COMPOUNDING
FIFTEEN AN EQUITY FROM THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
AID TO THE STUDENT. WE MUST
ALSO ENSURE THAT A FEDERAL
FUNDING IS NOT RECEIVED WE CAN
AVOID CARPAL CUTS DEBATES
FUNDING FOR A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY. THE RESULT OF THE
DIVESTMENT DURING THE LAST
RECESSION WE TURNED AWAY AND
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WE MUST
IDENTIFY OTHER MEANS THE
MAINTAINING SUPPORT FOR
UNIVERSITIES AND AVOIDING CUTS
THAT WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT.
CURRENT AND PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU AYE NUMBER FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
HEALTHCARE AND SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WAS AWARE OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES BUDGET
REQUEST THAT HAVE BEEN THE
PERSON AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
ABOUT YOUR REQUEST FOR THE
TRACK THE DRAMATIC RISE IN ANTI
AGING HARASSMENT USING A PHOBIA
BUT OUR COMMUNITY ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING DID A COOK AT
NINETEEN THE BUDGET REQUEST A
JOINT PROPOSAL I'M A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION AND THE
ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT. DOES HAPPEN OF
STATE AND HIS LA. THE ONE TIME%
INVESTMENT WOULD ALLOW OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THAT THE
PILOT NUMBER WITH MUCH NEEDED
RESPECTED EDUCATION AND
ACTIONABLE INFORMATION ALSO
INCREASE THE LANGUAGE
ACCESSIBILITY AND MULTIPLE
ASIAN LANGUAGES FOR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
IMPACTED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AYE NUMBER FORTY OR
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MY
VALLEY KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE. STUDENT SUCCESS IS
CRITICAL TO OUR STATE ECONOMY
AND WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU
PRIORITIZE UNDOCUMENTED IN PART
TIME STUDENT AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHO ARE LEFT OUT OF
THE FEDERAL CARE ACT ALLOTMENT
CALCULATION. THAT YOU
PRIORITIZE TRANSPARENCY OF EACH
SEGMENT NEWS A FEDERAL AND
STATE DOLLARS SPENT IN RESPONSE
TO THE CORONA VIRUS INCLUDING
REFUNDS AND EMERGENCY AID TO
STUDENTS AND THE REMAINING GAP.
AND THAT YOU PRIORITIZE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS THEY%
ARE POINTS TO RECEIVE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE THEATER WHEN
YOU FEET SPECIFICALLY WHEN YOU
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE STAR BY EACH
OF THE SEGMENT. THANK YOU TO
THE ADMINISTRATION WE LOOK FOR
TO WE CAN. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU NEXT DOOR TO
WHITE NUMBER NINE. MY NUMBER
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. NEXT PHOTO I
NEVER SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NOW AND I AM A BOARD
MEMBER WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
THE INCOMING STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT FOR SACRAMENTO STATE
I DO WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR ENSURING THAT THE REDUCTION
TO NOT IMPACT THE FINANCIAL AID
THAT OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE- BUT
I'M STILL DEFINITELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CURRENT IS BEING
PROPOSED. PARTICULARLY OUR
CONCERN IS WITH THE STUDENT
ACADEMIC SUCCESS- TWENTY
SIXTEEN TALKING OF STATE HAS
INCREASED OUR FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE. 132% WHICH IS
BAKER STUDENTS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. IN DEBT. AND I SEE
THAT THERE'S NO WAY THAT THESE
REDUCTIONS WOULDN'T IMPACT OUR
ABILITY TO KEEP GROWING THIS
GRADUATION RATE AND WILL
DEFINITELY STRUGGLE THAT SERVE
STUDENTS ACADEMICALLY. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. YOUR NEXT DOOR
TO WHITE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ALEX GRAVES
WITH THE I. T. VIDEO- WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND GALLAGHER- FOR RAISING THE
POINT OF THAT PROPOSED CUTS OF
OVER A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING OUR INSTITUTIONS-
REGARDING AT T. WE HAVE OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
ADMITTED IN. FALL TWENTY
NINETEEN COMPARED ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED OVER THE PRIOR FALL
THIRTY NINE SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATING FLOWS BENJAMIN
THIS WORK ON BEHALF OF OUR
SECTOR TO ARTICULATE THAT
PATHWAY HAPPY TO CONNECT WITH
ANY OF YOU OR YOUR STAFF
FURTHER- OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
MINISTRATION. HAS THE AUTHORITY
IN STATUTE TO MAKE THIS CAT
WE'VE NOW GOT THE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH A DRASTIC CUT
FOR CAL GRANT STUDENTS- WITH
ECONOMIC STRAIN BEING PLACED ON
FAMILY DâN INSTITUTIONAL. THE
REALITY IS THAT MANY
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO BACK FILL THIS CUT FOR
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
INSTITUTIONAL A- PARTICULARLY
CAN. THE HARM OF THOUSAND CUT
FOR THE STATE. WEIGHED AGAINST
THE BENEFITS THE STATE AND
SAVING OF ABOUT NINE MILLION ON
A FIFTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL- YOU SO WELL BECAUSE
THE ALLOWABLE UNDER STATUTE THE
QUESTION THE NEED TO DO SO FOR
ALL INCOME STUDENT AT THIS
TIME. THEY'RE SMALLER TO THERE.
GALLAGHER JAPAN'S AT OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE. ON ON HOW TO REPORT
ON OUR EIGHTY COMMITMENT ENSURE
THE STUDENTS ARE SUPPORTED
RIGHT OW WHAT ARE YOU TO
REJECT THAT PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU NEXT
DOOR TO WHITE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BUT THE
FRONT BUDGET PLAN WITH BE A
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU THE DAY
THAT- I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE GOVERNOR FOR BIGGIE
SHORE THAT THAT STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO KEEP GOING TO SCHOOL.
AT THE FINANCIAL AID IS
COVERED- BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO LIKE TO ASK THAT THE-
COMMITTEE RECONSIDER- CUTTING
THE UC IN BUDGET. THAT ALREADY
PAYING FOR SO MUCH THROUGH A
REDUCTION ON ON CAP ON STUDENTS
WANT TO GO THROUGH ON CAMPUS
HOUSING HAVING TO PAY FOR DID
YOU WANT TO. AND REQUIRED
ONLINE LIKE THE THING FOR YOU
CASH MATERIAL STUDENTS NEED TO
LEARN FROM- YEAH. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER TO Y. NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THAT THE
CODE EVEN IN IN I AM A CALLING
TO REPRESENT YOU CAN GET CRISIS
AND ALSO THAT WE CAN FOR OUR
PROTECTION SENATE BUT TO GET
EVERY REPRESENT OVER ONE POINT
THREE MILLION STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS. RECALLING TRONG WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED YOU DIDN'T
GET BLOWN WORKING GROUP AND
OUTREACH BUT ITEM. HOUSE UNDER
THE COLLAR. EIGHT ARE WE WORK
AND WE COULD MEET WITH OTHER
STUDENTS BAR ADVOCATE IN THE
WHOLE HUNDRED. FAR WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. WE FOUND THAT QUITE
BUT MANY RESPONDENTS FIND A
BETTER KNOWN THROUGH THE THIRD
UNTRUSTWORTHY AND THOSE THAT
FIND UNTRUSTWORTHY. AND ONLY
20% BELIEVE THAT THE
INFORMATION FROM YOUR LOAN
SERVICER PROPERTY AND ANY OUT
PRETTY. DURING THE COPA BANKING
CRISIS GETTING ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR STUDENT
DEBT AND HOW TO RELIEVE IT IS
CRUCIAL AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE-
HAVE. A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATION
AND PERFORM STRONG OUTREACH.
FOR THAT BOTH AT THE END OF
THE- SPECTRUM CENTER STRONGLY.
pNEXT CALLER. THANK YOU NEXT
RIGHTS WHY NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ERICA REMEMBER WHAT THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WE
FIND ON TO THE LETTER
SUPPORTING OUR AND DOCUMENTED
STUDENT POPULATION WE DID ALSO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE THAT
WILL PROVIDE MORE DETAILED. BUT
WE DO WANT TO SUPPORT WE SHOULD
BEGIN TO CUT TO THE STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND THE PRIVATE NOT FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS AND TO NOT
PULL THE TRIGGER ON THE CAL
GRANT NUMBER. ROOM AS WELL. AND
WE DO HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR SOME STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY BARRIERS- IN
FINANCIAL AID- THAT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT AND REMOVED IF
POSSIBLE. BUT WE DO SUPPORT
PROVIDING AS MUCH MONEY AS
POSSIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE DO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION. TO
REMOVE THE PERFORMANCE SPACE
COMPONENT OF THE STUDENTS ARE
NOT FUNDING FORMULA. WE URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
KIDS YOU AND THE UC ESPECIALLY
GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. INITIATIVE AS
WE LOOK AT THE LARGEST INCOMING
WHAT YOU KNOW CLASS. THAT WE
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW CALLER. THANK
YOU NETWORK ALLY NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- THIS IS MARK MCDONALD THE
CAL GROUP ON THE APPLE BUT NOT
BOTH LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT INCLUDING BY TEN
DOLLARS CHEAPER KERN AND THE
SAN BERNADINO DISTRICTS- WHEN
YOU COUNT FEDERAL FUNDING AND
ONE THAT'S TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH.
RELATIVE REDUCTION UNDER THE
MERRY REVIVED- COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE CRITICAL TO JOB
TRAINING FOR THIS PANDEMIC. AND
FOR THE RECOVERY WE ALSO THE
LEAST FUNDING PERSON. AND THIS
MAY REVISE WOULD ONLY
EXACERBATE. WE REQUEST THAT
RESOURCES BE TARGETED THE BEST
THE CLOSEST TO OUR STUDENTS SO
THAT WE CAN ROLL THOSE STUDENTS
AND PROMOTE ACCENTS. AND WE
WOULD ALSO REQUEST THAT SHOULD
REDUCE SMALL STATE OF FEDERAL
MONEY BECOME AVAILABLE THAT ITS
FIRST GOES TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU KNOCKED
OVER TO Y. NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON PERSONAL ACCOUNTS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY A
SITUATION WE OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED 10% GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION TO BE A HERO IN
ADDITION A SUPPORT THE USE OF
RESERVE FUND BY THE CST TO OFF
THE ANY GENERAL FUND REDUCTION.
A ALL THE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING FOR.
INSTRUCTION IN A LOGICAL
TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
EVERYTHING ANNOUNCEMENT
REGARDING ONLINE INSTRUCTION
FOR THE FALL SEMESTER.
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KNOW
STUDENT TUITION. INCREASES
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. HE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANYTHING THAT ROCK- MY
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS DIRECTOR
AND UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT YOU
CAN RIVERSIDE AND A
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO
URGE THE COMMITTEE NOT TO CUT
THE BUDGET BECAUSE WE NEED THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
IMPACT THE CRACKED WITH HAVE
HAD ON THE UC ATTEMPT THAT
BLANKET ACROSS THE PUBLIC
SECTOR DID NOT CONSIDER THE
FACT. THAT DIFFERENT AREAS
HAVING CREE GREATER LOSSES AT
THE YOU SEE THE UNIVERSITY HAD
TO CLICK OVER ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AND INCREASING
AND LOCK THAT BECAUSE THE CALL
THE NINETEENTH AND VERY
FINANCIALLY AND PEOPLE. THE
URGE THAT COMMITTEE CAN MEET
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
AND A MINUTE COALITION ASKS FOR
THE U. B. WE NEED TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION I'M GOING TO
MAINTAINING YOU CAN DOCUMENT
PROGRAMS ON OUR CAMPUSES. AND
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ONE KIND
FUNDS TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO WERE LEFT OUT OF
THE CARE ACT ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. EITHER VITAL FUNDS THAT
ARE GONNA CONTINUE TO
PROTAGONIZADA RESOURCES. ARE
THE MUCH NEEDED- COMMUNITY AND
BUT REJECT ME. ON MY- THANK.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. BOOK
YOUR NEXT RECORD ALLY NUMBER
TWO NINE THREE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR OF THE- WITH
THE TAX ON THE PROFITS FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE SHOULD DIRECTOR
OF THE U. S. OFFICIAL. I ARE.
ACCORDING TO THE SUPPORT OF A
LIFE. I THAT WERE MADE THE
CALIFORNIA OF THAT POLISH AND
PEOPLE WITH RESPECT IN IN ARE
YOU SEE THAT WHICH WILL HAVE A
DOG ON THE SERVICES FOR OUR YOU
A DOCTOR OF PROGRAM AND TO HAVE
THEM DOLLARS WHAT TOPIC BOOK
BUT I EIGHT ARE. A LOT OF BUT
FORGET ABOUT OF THE YOU CAN
INCREDIBLE. OR ARE THE CIRCUIT
ARE EEDED FOR ALL ABOUT THE I
DON'T TO BE CALLED. WE SHOULD
SUPPORT. AT ALL GEN A BLANKET
HAVE DIFFERENT BECAUSE UP TO
THE UC BUT- COULD NOT. BE
IMPACT WILL HAVE THE NEXT UNIT
WILL BE APPRECIATE OUR THE
MEMBERS. OUGHT COMING IN BUT-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALL.
THANK YOU NEXT TOOK TO LIVE
NUMBER A PER GOT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ENTER MY OF THE
CALIFORNIA KILLER SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA WE PLEASED TO HAVE A
VIDEO OF THE- ACTION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION IT COULD THOSE
OF A LOT OF. IT'S PAYMENT OUR-
YEAH WILL BE. OUR TROOPS BATES
FUNDING. SORRY WE ARE ABOUT
THREE OF BATES BUT THE SHORT TO
THE COMPLETE WHERE IT WOULD
AFTER YOU DO A WERE WILL RETURN
BUDGETS TO THE FACT ISSUE. AND
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMICAL
BETWEEN COLLEGE THAT STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. BE CUT ONLY
AT THE RESULT OF ONE OF THE
LOCAL LEVEL. GREAT SELECTION
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO LIE UP A TWO CALL
I HAVE. GOOD EVENING COMMANDER
THANK FOR NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
THING SUPPORT FOR TWO ITEMS
PARTICULARLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED STUDENT THAT LONG
WORKGROUP AN OUT REACH BUDGET
IDENTITY HOUSE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA TO DATE COMMISSION.
EVEN READ THAT FEDERAL AND
STATE RESPONSES TO COVER
NINETEEN TO PROVIDE
UNPRECEDENTED TEMPORARY REALLY.
EMBARRASSED ME TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION ON HOW
BEST NAVIGATE THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS. NOW MORE THAN EVER
SPECIAL REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY RETAIN THE BUDGET ITEM
THE PARTY YOU BORROWER IS THE
KEY COMPONENT FOR ANY ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLAN. SECOND WE
CONTINUE OUR STRONG SUPPORT
ACCOUNT RIGHT WHICH WILL BE
AFFECT GOING INTO THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN ADULT LEARNERS BUT TO
RETURN TO COLLEGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER TO LIE NUMBER
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER NINETY FOUR YEAR OPEN.
EXTRAVERTED NUMBER AT NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS EVA JENNINGS AND I'M A CO
CHAIR OF THE ADVOCACY COMMITTEE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE THE LARGEST WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROVIDER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HISTORICALLY WHEN
THE ECONOMY PICKED A DOWNTURN
OUR ENROLLMENT DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED AS UNDER EMPLOYED IN
UNDER SKILL CALIFORNIANS INVOKE
UPSCALE IN ORDER TO FIND OR
INCREASED EMPLOYMENT OPTIONS.
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM FUNDING WILL
INHIBIT OUR EFFORTS TO PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK WHICH IS A
CRITICAL WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
THE ECONOMIC STABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA STABLE AND
CONSISTENT STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM FUNDING WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO ENSURE THE STATE RECOVERS
FROM THE ECONOMIC ILL AT THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT
BROUGHT UPON A- STRONG WORK
FORCE REQUIRE STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM PLANNING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NECK CALLER. THANK
NUMBER EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE AS A
STRING OF THE UC AT THE END OF
THE RIVER REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE CITY DISTANCE EACH IRVINE
ASKING THE PLEASE CONSIDER THE
CONSIDERABLE IMPACT THAT A
BUDGET CUTS WILL BE ON OUR
EDUCATION WE ARE DEBATING ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOST TO BECAUSE THE NINETEEN.
CUTTING THE UC BUT FURTHER WITH
THE IMPACT YOUR EDUCATION. EVEN
COULD BE SEEN BUDGET AND ALSO
ON BEHALF O THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE SUPPORTING
THE BUDGET ASK MADE BY THE
CALIFORNIA HAD YOU EDUCATION
DOCUMENTED COALITION WHICH
SPECIFICALLY ASKING FOR TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
UNCLAIMED FUNDS MAINTAIN ARE
UNDOCUMENTED SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
IN TWO POINT FIVE A ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR FINANCE PLATE.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. YOUR
ACTUAL GO TO LIE NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT RETURN MEMBERS
CAN BAKER FOR THE MACON
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA.
GOING TODAY ONE OF THE STOCK
ANTI ASIAN HE COULD MEASURE TO
THAT YOU RECEIVED FROM THE
YACHT CAUCUS WHO COMMUNITY THIS
IS A MODEST ONE TIME INVESTMENT
UP WOULD ALLOW CRUCIAL SUPPORT
FOR THE ASIAN COMMUNITY TO
CONTINUE DOCUMENTING ANALYZING.
MAGNITUDE NATURE OF THE VERY
TROUBLING INCIDENT THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IN CALIFORNIA
ENTERED YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU NEXT DOOR TO THE LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING I'M DEBBIE KLEIN
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL CONTINUES TO
MAINTAIN FULL TIME FACULTY
FUNDING AND THE EAGLE PS
CATEGORICAL AND WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON
ENSURING ACCESS AND EQUITY.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TRAIN
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST RESPONDERS
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE ESSENTIAL
AND GETTING US THROUGH THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WE HOPE
THE ASSEMBLY WILL PRIORITIZE
FUNDING THAT FOCUSES ON STUDENT
ACCESS. TO MITIGATE HARM TO OUR
ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
ACCREDITED COLLEGES WE
RECOMMEND ELIMINATING HELP. ITS
WOULD OFFSET PROPOSED CUTS THAT
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
INCLUDING CUTS TO PART TIME
FACULTY SUPPORT AND IT'S
STATEWIDE ACADEMIC SENATE. TO
ADDRESS THE LONG TERM FLAWS IN
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA THE PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING ALLOCATION SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED. YOUR CONTINUED TO
OF THAT. TO THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
EXTRAVERT TO LIE NUMBER SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I KNOW YOU ARE
OPEN. NEXT DOOR TO LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY DARK BLUE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M NOT
WHAT ARE THE WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION YARD
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY GROUP
FOCUSED ON WORKFORCE EDUCATION
AND TRAINING POLICIES THAT THE
TO CREATE ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN RESPONSE
TO THE MAY REVISED WE ARE
THANKFUL THAT THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH SO MANY LOWER
INCOME STUDENTS AND ADULT
LEARNERS RELY ON BUT THEN CAME
IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
ALTHOUGH WE UNDERSTAND THE
FISCAL CHALLENGES. STILL LIE
AHEAD. VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT CUTS BEING PROPOSED
TO CRITICAL EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE TRAINING INITIATIVE.
BOB OR THE NUMBERS WHERE WE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE OUR STATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY STRATEGY
WHICH MEANS INVESTING IN
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND EXPENSE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES TO THE
STATE OF UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. ACTUALLY TO MANY
LOW WAGE WORKERS WILL BE
RETURNING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND OTHER TRAINING PROGRAM
AFTER LOSING EMPLOYMENT TO
COVER NINETEEN THANK YOU AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU TO SEND A REMINDER IF
YOU DO WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
IT WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER NINE
YOU ARE OPEN YOU MAY HAVE YOUR
LINE I KNEW. NEXT TO GO TO THE
LINE OF NUMBER SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIND SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT TO LINE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MEMBERS OF STEP TOO MANY
ANALYSTS AT LEE AND I'M A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CAL STATE
UNIFICATION WE DO ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUED FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING STUDENT
AFFORDABILITY ESPECIALLY FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE HARDEST
HIT BY THIS PANDEMIC. JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE DIDN'T HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS THEY WERE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE HIGH NUMBER
OF AN EMPLOYMENT AND WE ON TOP
THAT AND SECONDLY SAYS THAT WE
CAN'T AFFORD ARE STRUGGLING TO
PAY FOR NECESSITIES. I ALSO
WANTED TO KNOW THAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IN INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR ARE
STRUGGLING AS NO EMERGENCY
FEDERAL FUNDING HAS BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AN INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUS AS I LEFT TO JUST TRY TO
FIGURE IT OUT IN REALITY TO
CREATE EMERGENCY GRANT. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE ISSUE AND
IT'S STUDENTS ARE NOT FORGOTTEN
IN THIS CRISIS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. SELECT OVER TO LINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WE OFTEN ON THE OUTLOOK.
EACH REPRESENTING THE HALF MOON
ON THE CAMPUS WITH THE- WE
UNDERSTAND THE MAP OF THE
IMPACT THAT COULD BE NINETEEN A
CREDITOR NATION AND AT THANK
YOU I NEED YOU STUDENT
NAVIGATING THROUGH THEIR OWN
UNIQUE SITUATION MAKING
DIFFICULT DECISIONS I HAD. TO
HAVE DIFFERENT THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WELL THE EDUCATION AB
WELL THAT CONCERN WITH THE
DAMAGE OF THE PANDEMIC. ME THAT
HOW. TEACHERS DOCTORS LATER.
RESEARCHERS IN OF THE TWENTY
SITTING IN YOUR- AT EXCEPT.
BACK FISHING OR IN THE FUTURE.
IT THIS TRIAL THE STATE MUCH
ENSURE THAT COMPANY BUT THE
BAND CONTINUED TO BE TO ALLOW
STUDENTS MYSELF. TO
MATRICULATING EDUCATE BUT-
THANK YOU SIR AND THE RUNNING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATION
TO KEEPING. STATE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU ALL GO TO
LINE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU BOB TURNED GUARDIAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS JEAN I HAVE ON THE INNER
CHANCELLOR OF THE COPTER COPY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT ON
CALLING TO URGE THAT YOU ENSURE
THAT THE BUDGET CONTAINS. A
CONTINUATION OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IT WAS IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO
GOVERNOR SEVEN COULD IT IN THE
BAY REVISED. HOWEVER STAND IT
THESE ARE DIFFICULT BUDGET CONS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL. MOST
LIKELY TAKE THAT 10% CUT IF THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA
IF ENACTED AT THAT EXISTS TODAY
SOME DISTRICTS WILL TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL TEN FIFTEEN. 20% CUT
ON TOP OF THAT TEN PERCENT-
ACCORDING TO THE MY DISTRICT
THAT WOULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
SEVEN POINT 5% CUT IN THE
FUNDING FORMULA- DOCTRINE
EXTERNSHIP THREAT THIS IS NOT
AN ADDITIONAL BUDGET ITEM WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE JUST WANT TO
INSURE THAT THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION. EXTENDED THE TO
ALLOW US TO WORK ON THE FUNDING
FORMULA THANK YOU THANK. YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU NOT
OVERCOME NUMBER SIX GO AHEAD.
HENRY BERGH BALL MAY
REPRESENTING THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL- WHICH IS A BUSINESS
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS HUNDREDS OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE BAY
AREA. WE WANTED TO VOICE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR HELP RIGHT
COLLEGE COPPER COLLEGES
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
AND ADAPT TO CHANGE FASTER
GIVEN THAT THE ONLINE
COMPETENCY BASED APPROACH THAT
ALLOWS STUDENTS TO MOVE AT
THEIR OWN PACE. THIS IS THE
TIME FOR EXPANSION AND
DEVELOPMENT IN ONLINE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES GIVEN THAT STAY
AT HOME ORDERS- ENACTED BY KOBE
EIGHTEEN. THE SCALP AYE
COLLEGES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
WORKFORCE NO TIME WHEN THIS
KIND OF INVESTMENT CENTRAL
THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FOR YOUR
TIME WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU KNOCKED
OVER TO LIE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE HER
AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
REVENUES- INCLUDING- THE
SPENDING ADDITIONAL TAX CREDIT.
CARDS TO PROVIDE EFFICIENT
FUNDING FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. YOUR
NATIONAL GUARD PROVIDE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CREEK IN THE WIRE
WESTERN REGION DIRECTORS AGAIN
INVINCIBLE. INVINCIBLE WHAT
ABOUT HER BOTH GOOD AND BAD MOM
THE PROOF OUTREACH BUDGET ITEM
FOR THE HOUSE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA EIGHT CONNECTION
HELPING PIZZA BOTTLERS ME
TIMELY AND ACCURATE INFORMATION
ON HOW TO BETTER NAVIGATE THIS
ECONOMIC CRISIS. ACTUALLY IN
CONSIDERATION. WITH THE FEDERAL.
ON AT NIGHT. THE BORROWERS I
SPENT TO UNDERSTAND THIS THAT
MOM AND THAT THE TO HELP THEM
DURING THE FENDER NOW MORE THAN
EVER TELEPHONE HAS OF THE- SURE
THAT HOW WITH LOWERED HAVE
ACCESS TO RELIABLE INFORMATION
PLEASE BUDGET. THANK YOU
MODERATE THERE MORE CALL ON THE-
I HAVE NO MORE COMMON THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR SUB TO. IS A DURING.
THANK.